BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE NUMBER ONE
ON EDUCATION WILL COME TO ORDER.
AND AS A FIRST ORDER OF
BUSINESS, I'M GOING TO ASK FOR A
CALL OF THE ROLL. SENATOR LAIRD
HERE, SENATOR LAIRD HERE,
SENATOR MINH HERE. MEN HERE.
SENATOR WILK. OKAY. WE HAVE
ESTABLISHED A QUORUM, THIS IS
THE SIXTH HEARING OF THE
EDUCATION BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE.
AND THERE'S FOUR DISCUSSION
ITEMS ON THE AGENDA THAT WE WILL
HEAR EACH ITEM, IN TURN. AND WE
WILL TAKE ANY PUBLIC COMMENT
AFTER THE FOURTH ITEM. AND AS
USUAL, I WILL ASSESS HOW MANY
PEOPLE ARE HERE FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT AND THEN DETERMINE IF
THERE'S A LENGTH OF THE TIME FOR
PEOPLE MAKING A, PUBLIC COMMENT.
AND I WOULD JUST SAY AT THE
BEGINNING, AS I'M GOING TO SAY
AT THE END, IF YOU HAVE AN
INTEREST IN ANY OF THE ITEMS AND
YOU CANNOT TESTIFY TODAY, YOU'RE
WATCHING REMOTELY OR YOU WON'T
BE HERE AT THE RIGHT TIME, WE
CAN TAKE COMMENTS CGRTS BY GOING
TO THE BUDGET COMMITTEE WEBSITE,
OR BY WRITING THE BUDGET
COMMITTEE AT THE ADDRESS THAT'S
ON THE WEBSITE. AND WE WOULD
APPRECIATE ANY COMMENTS. AS I
MENTIONED, THIS IS THE SIXTH
HEARING. WE ARE NOT MAKING
DECISIONS YET ON INDIVIDUAL
ITEMS, BUT WE WILL BY THE TIME
THE REVISED BUDGET COMES OUT IN
MAY, WE'LL HAVE AIRED EVERY
MAJOR EDUCATION BUDGET ITEM FOR
BOTH K THROUGH 12 AND HIGHER
EDUCATION AND TRIED TO SEND
SIGNALS OR GENERAL DIRECTIONS ON
ITEMS THAT WE DON'T THINK, HAVE
BEEN WORKED OUT YET OR OR NEED
WORK. AND THAT BRINGS US TO OUR
FOUR ITEMS TODAY. AND THE FIRST
ITEM IS FEDERAL FUNDS STATUS.
AND THE PANEL AND I INVITE THEM
TO COME UP WILL BE MELISSA NG
FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE,
DAN MERWIN FROM THE DEPARTMENT
OF EDUCATION, AND MICHAEL FERRIS
FROM THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE. AND WHILE THEY ARE
COMING UP AND BEING SEATED, I
WOULD JUST SAY THAT FEDERAL
FUNDS FOR EDUCATION ACROSS THE
COUNTRY, AND PARTICULARLY TO
CALIFORNIA, WERE VERY IMPORTANT
POINT DURING THE PANDEMIC. THEY
REALLY BEGAN DURING THE
PANDEMIC. AND NOW THEY ARE
RUNNING OUT. AND SO THE QUESTION
IS, IS IN WHAT MANNER IS THAT
HAPPENING? WHAT'S THE IMPACT ON
SCHOOL BUDGETS? AND AS I MOVE
THROUGH MY OWN LEGISLATIVE
DISTRICT AND GO TO SCHOOLS AND
MEET WITH INDIVIDUAL TEACHERS,
PRINCIPALS AND SUPERINTEND
CGRTS, THEY TALK TO ME ABOUT THE
IMPACT OF THE FEDERAL FUNDING.
AND SO THAT IS WHAT OUR
DISCUSSION WILL BE ABOUT TODAY.
AND WE'LL GO IN THE ORDER THAT I
INTRODUCE PEOPLE. WE'LL START
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
WE'LL GO TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION AND THEN WE'LL GO TO
THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE. SO WELCOME TO THE
COMMITTEE. THANK YOU. IT'S MY
MIKE ON. IT WILL BE TURNED UP
HERE. GOOD MORNING, CHAIR
MELISSA NG WITH THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE I DON'T HAVE ANY
PREPARED REMARKS RELATED TO THIS
INFORMATIONAL ITEM, BUT I'M
AVAILABLE FOR ANY QUESTIONS.
OKAY. THEN WE'LL GO TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION. GOOD
MORNING, CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE. I AM DAN MERWIN,
ADMINISTRATOR FOR K¾T EAST
FISCAL POLICY OFFICE IN THE
GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS DIVISION. AND
I'M JOINED BY I MIGHT NEED THE
MICROPHONE A LITTLE CLOSER TO
YOU. FAIR ENOUGH. WE'RE HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE STATE
SUPERINTENDENT OF PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION. AS NOTED IN THE
AGENDA, THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
PASSED THREE MAJOR PIECES OF
LEGISLATION THAT PROVIDE TC
EDUCATION WITH FUNDING TO
PREVENT, PREPARE FOR, AND
RESPOND TO THE COVID 19
PANDEMIC. IN ADDITION, THE STATE
HAS ALSO MADE SEVERAL
APPROPRIATIONS TO SUPPORT THE
RESPONSE EFFORTS OF OUR SCHOOLS,
INCLUDING TO SUPPORT IN-PERSON
LEARNING DURING THE HEIGHT OF
THE PANDEMIC, TO PROVIDE
EXPANDED LEARNING OPPORTUNITIES,
MITIGATE LEARNING LOSS, AND
PROMOTE LEARNING RECOVERY.
COLLECTIVELY, LEAS HAVE RECEIVED
APPROXIMATELY 41.5 BILLION IN
STIMULUS FUNDING SINCE EARLY
2020. MUCH OF THIS FUNDING HAS
BEEN MADE AVAILABLE
RETROACTIVELY FOR EXPENSES BACK
TO MARCH 2020, AND HAS EXPIRED
IN WAVES. THUS FAR, 13.8 BILLION
HAS EXPIRED, ENCOMPASSING THE
CORONAVIRUS RELIEF FUND AND THE
EMERGENCY AND SECONDARY SCHOOL
EMERGENCY RELIEF FUND. SORRY
ELEMENTARY AND SECONDARY SCHOOL
EMERGENCY RELIEF FUND, OR IF THE
CHAIR WILL PERMIT ESSER FUNDS,
ONE AND TWO. THERE IS ALSO THE
GOVERNOR'S EMERGENCY EDUCATION
RELIEF FUND, KNOWN AS GEAR FUND
ONE AND TWO. LÀ KNOW YOU DEFINE
THE ACRONYM THE FIRST TIME.
THAT'S AT LEAST THE RULES. OKAY,
GOOD GOOD GOOD WORK. ESSER IS A
LITTLE BIT CUMBERSOME. NOT JUST
YOUR COLLEAGUE HAD A START AT
THE PREVIOUS HEARING, BUT HE GOT
THERE. THERE'S A THERE'S A
SIMILAR ACRONYM THAT WILL ALSO
COME UP. SO LEAS HAVE EXPENDED
99.69% OF THESE FUNDS
COLLECTIVELY, THE LATEST OF
WHICH NEEDED TO BE OBLIGATED BY
SEPTEMBER 30TH, 2023 AND
LIQUIDATED BY JANUARY 28TH OF
THIS YEAR. THE NEXT ROUND OF
FUNDING TO EXPIRE, WHICH
INCLUDES ALL FUNDS FROM THE
AMERICAN RESCUE PLAN, PASSED IN
MARCH 2021, TOTALS 19.7 BILLION
FOR FEDERAL FUNDS. ALL FUNDS
MUST BE OBLIGATED BY SEPTEMBER
30TH OF THIS YEAR AND LIQUIDATED
BY JANUARY 28TH OF NEXT YEAR,
WITH VERY LIMITED EXCEPTIONS.
THE LARGEST POTS OF FUNDING
WITHIN THIS GROUP ARE THE ESSER
THREE FUNDS, WHICH ACCOUNT FOR
13.5 BILLION, AND THE 5.7
BILLION THAT REMAINS FROM THE
IN-PERSON INSTRUCTION GRANT AND
THE EXPANDED LEARNING
OPPORTUNITIES GRANT, WHICH IS
NOT TO BE CONFUSED WITH THE
ONGOING FUND MADE AVAILABLE FROM
THE EXPANDING LEARNING
OPPORTUNITIES PROGRAM, WHICH IS
WHAT YOU HEARD A FEW WEEKS AGO
BASED ON THE LATEST QUARTERLY
REPORTING, WHICH ACTUALLY JUST
CLOSED LAST FRIDAY, THE 12TH,
72% OF ALL ESSER THREE FUNDS AND
75% OF THE REMAINING FEDERAL
FUNDS THAT MAKE UP THE EXPANDED
LEARNING OPPORTUNITIES GRANT ARE
ALREADY EXPENDED. AND
IMPORTANTLY, THESE NUMBERS ONLY
REPRESENT FULLY EXPENDED FUNDS
AND DO NOT TAKE INTO ACCOUNT
OBLIGATED AMOUNTS. WE WOULD ALSO
NOTE THAT LEAS HAVE PLANNED HOW
THEY WILL USE THESE FUNDS OVER
THE LIFE OF THE PROGRAMS,
PARTICULARLY FOR THE ESSER THREE
FUNDING THAT INCLUDED A ROBUST
STAKEHOLDER PROCESS THAT WAS
REQUIRED BY FEDERAL LAW. LEAS
HAVE PROVIDED NO INDICATION THEY
WILL BE UNABLE TO USE THE
REMAINING FUNDS, THOUGH WE DO
ANTICIPATE THAT SOME OF THE
LARGER PROJECTS UNDERTAKEN BY
LEAS WITH THESE LAST ROUNDS OF
FUNDING, SUCH AS HVAC
REPLACEMENTS OR FACILITY
UPGRADES, ARE MORE LIKELY TO
EXPERIENCE DELAYS DUE TO ISSUES
SUCH AS SUPPLY CHAIN
INTERRUPTIONS AND THUS MORE
LIKELY TO SEEK THE EXTENDED LATE
LIQUIDATION APPROVAL. AS NOTED
IN THE AGENDA, LATE LIQUIDATION
PROVIDES LEAS WITH A TOTAL OF 18
MONTHS TO LIQUIDATE VALID
OBLIGATIONS RATHER THAN THE
STANDARD 120 DAYS, BUT THESE
STILL HAVE TO BE FOR FUNDS THAT
WERE PROPERLY OBLIGATED BY
SEPTEMBER 30TH. AS FOR WHAT LEAS
ARE USING THIS FUNDING FOR, WE
HAVE ANALYZED EXPENDITURE DATA
AND THERE ARE CLEAR TRENDS THAT
REALLY REFLECT DIFFERENT STAGES
OF THE PANDEMIC. THE MOST COMMON
EXPENDITURE DURING THE ONSET OF
THE PANDEMIC, BAR NONE, WAS
EDUCATIONAL TECHNOLOGY DEVICES
CONNECTIVITY, ALSO VERY HIGH ON
THE LIST? PERSONAL PERSONAL
PROTECTIVE EQUIPMENT AND
CLEANING SUPPLIES. AND JUST FOR
A POINT OF COMPARISON,
EDUCATIONAL TECHNOLOGY WAS 21.3
2.1 BILLION OF THE FIRST 6.8
BILLION THAT WAS AVAILABLE TO
LEAS. SO PRETTY SIGNIFICANT.
COLLECTIVELY, THIS MAKES IT
CLEAR TO US THAT LEAS INITIALLY
SPENT THEIR FUNDING ON
RESPONDING TO IMMEDIATE HEALTH
AND SAFETY NEEDS, AS WELL AS
SUPPORTING THE TRANSITION TO
DISTANCE LEARNING. AS WE SHIFTED
FROM PANDEMIC RESPONSE TO
PANDEMIC RECOVERY, LÀ SPENDING
AND EFFORTS TO PROMOTE LEARNING
ACCELERATION BECAME THE MAJOR
FOCUS TO THE POINT THAT TODAY,
IF YOU LOOK AT ESSER
EXPENDITURES ACROSS ALL
ITERATIONS OF THAT FUNDING,
YOU'LL SEE THAT LEAS ACTUALLY
SPENT MORE FUNDING ON LEARNING
ACCELERATION THAN THEY DID ON
EDUCATION TECHNOLOGY. AND THAT
DOESN'T TAKE INTO ACCOUNT FUNDS
OR PROGRAMS THAT HAVE AS THEIR
CORE REQUIREMENTS THAT FUNDS ARE
USED FOR LEARNING ACCELERATION,
WHICH INCLUDES THE 4.5 BILLION
FROM THE EXPANDED LEARNING
OPPORTUNITIES GRANT, OR 2.7
BILLION THAT WAS HAD TO BE SET
ASIDE FROM AN LEAS ESSER THREE
FUNDING SPECIFICALLY FOR
LEARNING RECOVERY. WE'VE ALSO
SEEN LÀ SPENDING ON STUDENT
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES AND
SOCIAL EMOTIONAL LEARNING, AS
WELL AS FACILITY REPAIRS THAT
REDUCE VIRUS TRANSMISSION OR
SUPPORT MENTAL AND EMOTIONAL
HEALTH. LOOKING SPECIFICALLY AT
THE EXPANDED LEARNING
OPPORTUNITIES GRANT, WE HAVE
SEEN LEAS USE THESE FUNDS
PRIMARILY TO SUPPORT
ACCELERATING PROGRESS TO CLOSE
LEARNING GAPS, TO PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL ACADEMIC SERVICES,
AND TO SUPPORT, INTEGRATE AND TO
PROVIDE INTEGRATED PUPIL
SUPPORT. THIS INCLUDES
ACTIVITIES SUCH AS TUTORING OR
SMALL GROUP INSTRUCTION,
DIAGNOSTIC PROGRESS MONITORING
AND BENCHMARK ASSESSMENTS, AND
HEALTH COUNSELING AND MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES. WE'VE ALSO SEEN
LEAS BRAIDING THEIR FUNDING TO
BUILD LONGER TUM PROGRAMS THAT
RESPOND TO THE ENTIRETY OF THE
NEEDS CREATED BY THE PANDEMIC,
NOT JUST THE IMMEDIATE NEEDS TO
PROTECT HEALTH AND SAFETY AND
SUPPORT DISTANCE LEARNING, BUT
TO FULLY SUPPORT NOT JUST
LEARNING RECOVERY, BUT LEARNING
ACCELERATION. AND THIS IS
THROUGH SERVICES SUCH AS
TUTORING, EXPANDED LEARNING
SETTINGS, AND MENTAL HEALTH AND
COUNSELING SERVICES. WHILE THE
FEDERAL FUNDING WILL EXPIRE THIS
YEAR, SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENTS
MADE BY THE LEGISLATURE WILL BE
AVAILABLE FOR THE NEXT 3 TO 4
YEARS, SUCH AS THE LEARNING
RECOVERY EMERGENCY BLOCK GRANT
OR THOSE INITIATIVES THAT THE
LEGISLATURE NOW HAS THE
OPPORTUNITY TO CONTINUE THROUGH
ACTION IN THIS BUDGET, SUCH AS
THE HOMELESS EDUCATIONAL
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE CENTERS
THAT ADDRESS THE NEEDS OF OUR
HOMELESS STUDENT POPULATION AND
WILL BE COVERED IN THE NEXT
ISSUE. THESE REPRESENT THE NEXT
STEPS IN THE CRITICAL PATH TO
FULL RECOVERY. BY BUILDING ON
WHAT HAS WORKED AND ALLOWING
ADDITIONAL TIME TO FURTHER
INTEGRATE THE MOST PROMISING
PRACTICES INTO REGULAR SCHOOL
BUDGETS. THANK YOU, AND WE'RE
HAPPY TO TAKE QUESTIONS AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME. GREAT WE'LL DO
THAT. THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE.
YES. TO THE LEO, GOOD MORNING,
MR. CHAIR. MICHAEL FERRIS WITH
THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE. WE DON'T HAVE ANY
SPECIFIC COMMENTS, BUT ARE
AVAILABLE TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU. I SORT OF
HAVE TWO QUESTIONS OF THIS. AND
ONE IS TO FOLLOW UP ON WHAT YOU
SAID, AND IT'S IN OUR AGENDA.
IT'S SORT OF THE ANTICIPATION OF
THE LOCAL AGENCIES AND WHAT,
THEY WILL APPLY FOR IN
LIQUIDATION EXTENSION REQUESTS.
DO YOU HAVE ANY FLAVOR FOR WHAT
THAT'S GOING TO BE? YES. AND
ALSO, UNFORTUNATELY, NO, WE HAVE
WHAT THE CURRENT EXPENDITURES
ARE CLEARLY READY FOR ELECTED
OFFICE. YOU'RE WE DO HAVE A VERY
CLEAR UNDERSTANDING OF WHERE
EXPENDITURES STAND TODAY. WHAT
WE DON'T HAVE A CLEAR
UNDERSTANDING IS OBLIGATIONS. WE
WILL HAVE THAT AS WE GET CLOSER
TO THE DEADLINE PERIOD. WE START
COLLECTING THAT, WITH WHAT WE
CALL FALL 2024 REPORTING AT THE
END OF SEPTEMBER, WE DO
PROJECTIONS. THEY ARE PRETTY
ROUGH THAT DO SHOW SOME AMOUNT
HANGING OUT THERE, THAT CHANGES
DEPENDING ON THE LENGTH OF THE
LIQUIDATION DEADLINE. IF YOU
HAVE A STANDARD LIQUIDATION
DEADLINE, YOU WOULD POTENTIALLY
HAVE MORE FUNDS UNEXPENDED
LONGER LIQUIDATION DEADLINE. YOU
CAN HAVE THOSE LARGER PROJECTS
THAT ARE HAVING CONTRACTOR
DELAYS, WHICH IS A COMMON ONE
THAT WE HAD WITH ESSER TWO
FUNDING OR BEING UNABLE TO GET,
SAY, THE HVAC EQUIPMENT THAT YOU
PURCHASED. IT JUST DIDN'T GET
DELIVERED IN TIME BECAUSE IT WAS
GETTING SHIPPED FROM WHEREVER,
WE DID HAVE A TOTAL OF 30
APPLICATIONS FOR THE ESSER TWO
YEAR TWO FUNDING. AND THAT WAS
FOR $6.7 BILLION IN FUNDING AT A
MUCH EARLIER POINT IN THE
PANDEMIC. WE'RE NOW LOOKING AT
THAT. MAYBE THIS LEADS TO MY
SECOND QUESTION, WHICH I THINK
EVERYBODY MIGHT WANT TO WEIGH
INTO LÀ, WHICH IS I'M TRYING TO
UNDERSTAND, WITH THE FEDERAL
FUNDS RECEDING AND SCHOOL
DISTRICTS LOCAL EDUCATION,
EDUCATION AGENCIES IS DEPENDING
ON THEM, AS THE FEDERAL FUNDS
SLIP AWAY. WHERE WAS THEIR, NEW
OBLIGATIONS PAID FOR? THERE THAT
SORT OF STRESS? THE DISTRICTS
GOING FORWARD WITHOUT HAVING
FEDERAL FUNDS IN THE MIX? I MEAN
, WHAT WHAT IS THE NET RESULT?
WE HAVE HEARD SORT OF THE THINGS
THAT WERE DONE WITH THE FEDERAL
FUNDS. BUT AS THEY PULL BACK,
IT'S SORT OF A LOT OF SCHOOL
DISTRICTS ARE TELLING ME THAT
THEY'RE REALLY IN TROUBLE IN
SOME WAYS BECAUSE THAT'S PULLED
BACK. HOW DO YOU ASSESS FROM THE
HIGHER LEVEL THE FEDERAL MONEY
NOT BEING THERE? AND I'LL START
WITH YOU BECAUSE YOU'RE LOOKING
LIKE YOU'RE READY TO TALK, BUT
THEN I'LL ASK FINANCE IN THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST IF THEY WISH
TO WEIGH IN. I THINK ONE THING
THAT WE CAN DO IS WE LOOK AT
WHEN WE LOOK AT THE EXPENDITURE
DATA, THERE'S CATEGORIES THAT
ARE CLEARLY A ONE TIME USE, A
FACILITY IMPROVEMENT IS NOT
GOING TO REQUIRE AN ANNUAL
BUDGET COMMITMENT OTHER THAN,
SAY, ROUTINE MAINTENANCE, BUT IF
YOU'RE DOING A TUTORING PROGRAM
AND THAT'S PROVEN TO BE
SUCCESSFUL AND THAT IS SOMETHING
THAT YOU WANT TO KEEP ONGOING
BECAUSE MAYBE YOUR TEST SCORES
ARE IMPROVING OR YOU'RE GETTING
HIGHER ATTENDANCE FROM AN
EXPANDED LEARNING OPPORTUNITIES
PROGRAM. NOT TO BE CONFUSED WITH
THE ACTUAL PROGRAM, BUT THAT
TYPE OF PROGRAM. THOSE WOULD BE
THE KINDS OF THINGS THAT, AS A
SCHOOL ADMINISTRATOR, I WOULD
WANT TO CONTINUE. I WOULD SAY,
WELL, CAN I MOVE THIS FUNDING
FOR THE NEXT FEW YEARS INTO MY
LEARNING RECOVERY EMERGENCY
BLOCK GRANT OR OTHER FUNDING, IS
THERE HOPEFULLY ENOUGH GROWTH IN
OUT YEARS IN LCFF THAT I CAN
CONTINUE THESE PROGRAMS? BECAUSE
IT'S THE STAFFING COSTS THAT ARE
GOING TO TAKE A LONG TIME. MAYBE
THE CONTRACTS ASSOCIATED WITH IT
IF YOU CONTRACTED SOMETHING OUT,
BUT THOSE WOULD BE THE TYPES OF
PROGRAMS THAT I THINK PUT THE
PRESSURE ON DISTRICT BUDGETS.
OKAY. ANYTHING TO ADD FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE? I DON'T
HAVE ANYTHING TO ADD TO THE
DEPARTMENT'S RESPONSE. I THINK
THESE FUNDS WERE I MEAN, I THINK
EVERYONE WAS AWARE THAT THESE
FUNDS WERE ONE TIME. SO I, I
THINK THE DEPARTMENT HAS BEEN
PROVIDING GUIDANCE ON KIND OF
THE USES OF THE FUNDS FOR ONE
TIME PURPOSES AND NOT TO
DEDICATE THEM TO ONGOING
PURPOSES FOR THIS VERY REASON
THAT IT WILL EVENTUALLY DROP OFF
AT SOME POINT. I APPRECIATE
THAT, BUT NOT EVERYBODY IS AS
RATIONAL AS YOUR STATEMENT JUST
INDICATED. LEGISLATIVE ANALYST
YEAH, THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR. I'M
NOT SURE WE HAVE ANY SPECIFIC
COMMENTS, BUT I JUST WANTED TO
REITERATE KIND OF TO MR.
MERWIN'S COMMENTS EARLIER THAT
THERE IS SEVERAL STATE FUNDING
SOURCES LIKE THE ARTS, MUSIC AND
INDUSTRY DISCRETIONARY
MATERIALS, BLOCK GRANT AND THE
LEARNING RECOVERY EMERGENCY
BLOCK GRANT THAT COULD BE USED
FOR SOME SIMILAR PURPOSES TO
SUPPORT STUDENTS THAT HAVE
HIGHER NEEDS. OKAY. THANK YOU
FOR THAT COMMENT. I THINK THE
MOST IMPORTANT THING WAS JUST TO
HIGHLIGHT THIS, BECAUSE IT IS
OUT THERE AND, AND IT IS
SOMETHING THAT PEOPLE ARE
REACTING TO. SO I REALLY
APPRECIATE YOUR COMMENTS AND
BEING HERE FOR THIS, THIS PANEL.
WE'LL SEE IF ANYBODY HAS PUBLIC
COMMENT. DO YOU HAVE A LAST
COMMENT? YES. JUST ONE THING TO
CONSIDER, THOUGH THE FUNDING
EXPIRES, A LOT OF THE
REQUIREMENTS AROUND THIS DON'T.
FOR SEVERAL YEARS, THE ANNUAL
REPORTING WHICH SOME OF YOUR
LEAS MAY HAVE REACHED OUT TO
YOUR OFFICE AND COMPLAINED WHY
K¾T REQUIRING 154 HOURS OF
REPORTING? IT'S A FEDERAL
REQUIREMENT AND IT'S MY JOB.
JUST THEN TO IMMEDIATELY REFER
THEM TO YOU. YES, YES. AND YES
IT IS, AND THEN WE REFER THEM TO
THEIR US CONGRESSMAN. SO THAT'S
HOW THAT GOES BECAUSE IT IS A
FEDERAL ELECTED OFFICE. YEAH.
OKAY BUT I APPRECIATE THAT
BECAUSE I HAVE HEARD ABOUT THAT.
AND I THINK THAT WILL BE A
QUESTION THAT MANY PEOPLE HAVE
AS IT, AS IT MOVES ON. SO THANK
YOU FOR BEING HERE FOR THIS AND
FOR PARTICIPATING IN THE
DISCUSSION. THÀNH. AND I KNOW
TWO OF YOU ARE REMAINING FOR THE
NEXT PANEL, IT'S THE HOMELESS
EDUCATION TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
CENTERS. IT WILL BE MELISSA NG
AGAIN FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. IT WILL BE WILLIAM
MCGEE FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION. AND AGAIN, IT WILL BE
MICHAEL FERRIS FROM THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE.
AND IN OPENING COMMENTS, WE'LL
GO IN THAT ORDER. SO WELCOME
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE, MELISSA
YANG WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. SO I'LL BE PROVIDING AN
OVERVIEW OF THE HOMELESS
EDUCATION TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
CENTERS PROPOSAL OR TEXT
INCLUDED IN THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET. THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
INCLUDES 1.5 MILLION ONGOING
PROPOSITION 98 GENERAL FUND TO
MAINTAIN SUPPORT FOR THE
HOMELESS, EDUCATION TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE CENTERS THAT WERE
ESTABLISHED THAT WERE FIRST
ESTABLISHED THROUGH THE AMERICAN
RESCUE PLAN ACT. HOMELESS
CHILDREN AND YOUTH FUNDS, WHICH
ARE AVAILABLE THROUGH JUNE 30TH,
2024. THIS FUNDING WILL CONTINUE
THE MOMENTUM AND INCREASING
HOMELESS YOUTH IDENTIFICATION
AND PROVIDING SUPPORTS TO
SCHOOLS SERVING THESE STUDENTS
TO IMPROVE THEIR ACADEMIC
OUTCOMES. WHILE EXISTING
STATUTES SPECIFIES THE
RESPONSIBILITIES OF THE HEAT TAX
PROPOSED IN TRAILER, BILL
INTENDS TO INCLUDE ADDITIONAL
PRIORITY PRIORITIES TO PROVIDE
HEAT TAX. A MORE PROACTIVE ROLE
IN SUPPORTING LEAS, WHICH
INCLUDE SPECIFIC PROVIDING
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE IN
IMPLEMENTING BEST PRACTICES IN
ADDITION TO DEVELOPING AND
DISSEMINATING BEST PRACTICES.
FOSTERING RELATIONSHIPS BETWEEN
COMMUNITY PARTNERS AND LEAS IN
EACH REGION, INCLUDING PROVIDING
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT AND
COACHING OPPORTUNITIES TO HELP
BUILD CAPACITY LOCALLY.
PROVIDING TARGETED TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE TO LEAS IDENTIFIED
FOR DIFFERENTIATED ASSISTANCE
FOR THEIR HOMELESS STUDENT
GROUP, WHICH INCLUDES HELPING
LEAS OPTIMIZE EXISTING FUNDING
STREAMS SUCH AS LCFF AND THE
SUPPLEMENTAL AND CONCENTRATION
GRANT FUNDING GENERATED BY THESE
STUDENTS, ESPECIALLY IF THERE
ARE SPENDING GAPS BETWEEN THESE
STUDENTS AND OTHER HIGH NEEDS
STUDENT GROUPS. AND FINALLY
WORKING COLLABORATIVELY WITH
LEAS TO UTILIZE AVAILABLE DATA
THROUGH THE CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
DASHBOARD OR OTHER LOCAL DATA
SOURCES TO IDENTIFY ACHIEVEMENT
GAPS AND HOW TO IMPLEMENT BEST
PRACTICES TO HELP IMPROVE
ACADEMIC OUTCOMES. THAT
CONCLUDES MY REMARKS, AND I'M
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS AT
THE APPROPRIATE TIME. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. MOVE TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION. WELCOME
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE. THANK
YOU. AND THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME
HERE. MY NAME IS WILLIAM MCGEE.
I'M THE DIVISION DIRECTOR FOR
THE STUDENT ACHIEVEMENT AND
SUPPORT DIVISION AT THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION. ON BEHALF OF THE
STATE SUPERINTENDENT, TONY
THURMOND. WE APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK ABOUT THE
WORK THAT THE HOMELESS EDUCATION
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE CENTERS
HAVE DONE AND SUPPORTED WITH IN
THE WORK THAT THEY NEED TO
CONTINUE TO DO. AND SO NOW THAT
I'VE HEARD, AS LONG AS WE
CLARIFY, I CAN START USING
ACRONYMS, BECAUSE THAT IS A LOT
TO SAY. THE HEAT TECHS ARE ALSO,
THE HEAT TECHS WERE ESTABLISHED
THROUGH A COMPETITIVE GRANT
PROCESS. THREE COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION WERE SELECTED TO
PROVIDE SUPPORT AND TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE TO OTHER COUNTY
OFFICES OF EDUCATION AND A
REGIONAL APPROACH, AND TO ASSIST
WITH CAPACITY BUILDING RESOURCES
AND TOOLS REQUIRED TO SUPPORT
THEIR LEADS. WITH THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE EDUCATION
FOR HOMELESS CHILDREN AND YOUTH
ACT ALSO KNOWN AS E, H, C ACT,
USING AMERICAN RESCUE PLAN,
HOMELESS CHILDREN AND YOUTH ALSO
REFERRED TO AS ARP H C FUNDS
FROM 21 EXCUSE ME 2021 TO 2024.
EACH HEAT TAC RECEIVED $1.5
MILLION EACH YEAR FOR THE THREE
YEAR INVESTMENT. THE HEAT TECHS
ARE ALSO RESPONSIBLE FOR
PROVIDING STATEWIDE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE AND PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT, SUCH AS HOSTING A
STATEWIDE HOMELESS EDUCATION
CONFERENCE, MONTHLY WEBINARS TO
PROVIDE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE,
AND MAINTAINING THE HEAT TAC
CENTER WEBSITE WHERE RESOURCES
ARE HOUSED. ONE OF THE TOP
PRIORITIES FOR THE HEAT TAX IS
TO ALWAYS ENSURE THAT THEIR WORK
AND THE WORK OF THE COUNTY
OFFICES IS SUPPORTED BY DATA.
THE HEAT TECHS WORK WITH OUR
VARIOUS DATA SYSTEMS AT THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION TO SUPPORT THAT WORK,
AND THE HEAT TAX HAVE DEVELOPED,
PRESENTED, RECORDED, AND POSTED
WEBINARS AND TIP SHEETS THAT
CORRESPOND TO THE NEEDS OF CEOS
ACROSS THE STATE, INCLUDING
PROPER IDENTIFICATION, IMMEDIATE
ENROLLMENT, SUPPORTING CHILDREN
AND YOUTH WHO ARE HOMELESS AND
ELIGIBLE FOR SPECIAL EDUCATION,
EARLY EDUCATION, AND HOMELESS
STUDENTS WHO IDENTIFY AS
LESBIAN, GAY, BISEXUAL,
TRANSGENDER, QUEER, AND
QUESTIONING THE WORK AND
ACTIVITIES THAT THE HEAT TAX
HAVE ACCOMPLISHED IN THE PAST
TWO YEARS ENSURE SIGNIFICANT
SUPPORT FOR CALIFORNIA'S MOST
VULNERABLE CHILDREN FOR THE PAST
TWO YEARS, AS I MENTIONED, THE
HEAT TAX HAVE DONE A VARIETY OF
WEBINARS. THEY HAVE TRACKED THE
NUMBER OF ATTENDEES AND YOUTUBE
VIEWS FOR THE WEBINARS, WEBINAR
ATTENDANCE, DEPENDING ON THE
TOPIC, HAS RANGED FROM 53
ATTENDEES TO OVER 341 ATTENDEES,
AND YOUTUBE VIEWS HAVE RANGED
FROM 70 VIEWS TO 154, DEPENDING
ON THE WEBINAR. THE MOST WELL
ATTENDED AND RECEIVED TRAININGS
HAVE BEEN FOR SCHOOL COUNSELORS
AND SUPPORTING TRANSPORTATION
RIGHTS FOR CHILDREN AND YOUTH,
WHICH HAVE SUPPORTED WITH
INCREASING ATTENDANCE,
FULFILLING GRADUATION
REQUIREMENTS AND AN OVERALL
INCREASE IN SCHOOL PARTICIPATION
SINCE THEIR INCEPTION IN
NOVEMBER OF 2021. EACH REGIONAL
HEAT TAC HAS LED PROVIDED
CUSTOMIZED SUPPORT TO THEIR
CEOS. THESE TASKS INCLUDE
CONDUCTING REGIONAL NEEDS
ASSESSMENT, PROGRAM EVALUATION,
AND CONDUCTING REGIONAL
MEETINGS. SO I WANTED TO TAKE A
MOMENT TO GIVE A LITTLE BIT OF
HISTORY ABOUT THE HEAT TAX. THE
WORK THAT THEY'VE DONE, AS WE
KNOW THAT THE FUNDING WILL
INSPIRE EXPIRE. IT WOULD BE
BENEFICIAL FOR THE STATE TO
ENSURE ON GOING FUNDS TO SUPPORT
THE CRUCIAL WORK OF THE HEAT TAX
AND SUPPORTING THE LEADS THAT
HAVE BENEFITED. FOR THIS THIS
WORK. THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING ME
TO SPEAK ABOUT THE EFFECTIVE
WORK THAT HEAT TAX HAVE DONE,
AND I'LL BE ABLE TO ANSWER
QUESTIONS AT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. AND
WE'LL MOVE ON TO THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST. THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR.
MICHAEL FERRIS WITH THE LAO, WE
DON'T HAVE SPECIFIC
RECOMMENDATIONS ON THE MERITS OF
THE PROPOSAL, BUT WE WOULD JUST
REITERATE OUR COMMENTS IN
EARLIER HEARINGS ABOUT THE
TIGHTNESS OF THE STATE BUDGET.
THE STATE BUDGET CAN CURRENTLY
CANNOT SUPPORT EXISTING K
THROUGH 14 PROGRAMS. SO ANY NEW
SPENDING, AS WELL AS EXTENSIONS
OF EXISTING SPENDING ADDS TO THE
CHALLENGE OF BALANCING THE
BUDGET. THAT CONCLUDES OUR
COMMENTS. HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS. I APPRECIATE YOUR
COMMENTS. I THOUGHT I'D MAKE A
BRIEF, A COMMENT AND SORT OF ASK
A QUESTION. AND THAT IS, I TRY
TO GET OUT IN MY OWN SENATE
DISTRICT, AND A FEW WEEKS AGO I
VISITED A HIGH SCHOOL IN MARINA
IN MONTEREY COUNTY THAT HAD JUST
THIS IMPRESSIVE PROGRAM, AND
THEY WERE COVERING SOME OF IT BY
THEMSELVES. AND THE COUNTY
OFFICE OF EDUCATION HAS A PERSON
THAT'S ASSIGNED TO 26 SCHOOL
DISTRICTS AND WAS REALLY HELPING
THEM. AND I VISITED WHERE THEY
HAVE SHOWERS, WASH MACHINES,
QUIET ROOMS, ON FRIDAY, THEY
PACK, VARIOUS BACKPACKS WITH
NONPERISHABLE FOOD AND ALLOW THE
STUDENTS TO TAKE IT TO WHEREVER
THEY'RE GOING AND JUST BRING
BACK THE PACKS WHEN THEY'RE
EMPTY. SOMETIME AT THE BEGINNING
OF NEXT WEEK. AND I WAS
SURPRISED AT SORT OF THE NUMBER
OF PEOPLE THAT WERE IN THE
CATEGORY THAT THEY HAD TO
UTILIZE THAT OUT, AND THERE WAS
JUST THIS WHOLE MIX OF FUNDING,
AND IT LOOKED LIKE THE FEDERAL
FUNDING WASN'T. SOME OF IT WAS
STEWART MCKINNEY ACT, AND IT
DIDN'T LOOK LIKE IT WAS
NECESSARILY GOING TO CONTINUE TO
WITNESS WHAT THE LAO
REPRESENTATIVE JUST SAID, THAT
THEY'RE HOPING FOR SOME EXTRA
MONEY, WHICH SEEMS JUST
DIFFICULT IN THE CURRENT
CIRCUMSTANCES TO BE ABLE TO
COVER EVERYTHING THEY'RE DOING.
AND, AND THAT THERE'S OTHER
MONEY THAT JUST IS SORT OF
FLOATS IN AND FLOATS OUT AND
THERE'S NO SORT OF ASSURANCE.
AND SO I GUESS THERE'S SOME
QUESTIONS THAT WERE IN THE
AGENDA, BUT I THINK ONE IS, IS
TO ME, THIS WAS AN EFFECTIVE
PRACTICE. THIS IS WHERE THEY ARE
ON THEIR OWN, ASSESSED WHAT WAS
NEEDED AND FIGURED OUT THE BEST
WAYS. THEY COORDINATED WITH THE
FOOD BANK. THAT'S WHY THEY HAD A
FOOD PANTRY AND HAD THE OTHER
STUFF. THEY, THEY REALLY AND
THERE WERE TIMES WHEN THERE WAS
NEGLECT OR ABUSE THAT WAS SORT
OF DETERMINED IN THIS PROCESS.
AND SO I GUESS MAYBE TO START
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION, HOW DO YOU LOOK
AROUND THE STATE AND SEE BEST
PRACTICES AT WHAT PEOPLE ARE
DOING AND REFLECT THEM TO OTHER
SCHOOL DISTRICTS OR OTHER
PEOPLE? THAT MIGHT BE
EXPERIENCING IT AND MIGHT NOT
HAVE HAD THE ABILITY TO RESPOND
THIS WAY? YEAH, YEAH. NO AND
THAT'S THAT'S A GREAT QUESTION.
AND IT SOUNDS LIKE YOUR VISIT
WAS ALSO POWERFUL. I KNOW THAT
SAN FRANCISCO HAS DONE SOME
THINGS SIMILAR WHERE THEY'VE
WORKED WITH THEIR COUNTY AND THE
CITY AND THE COMMUNITY, AND THEY
ALLOW FOR CHILDREN AND THEIR
FAMILIES TO SLEEP IN THE SCHOOL,
AND THEY HAVE THE SHOWER SYSTEM
SET UP. AND SO GOING TO YOUR
QUESTION ABOUT HOW DO WE REFLECT
ON BEST PRACTICES, THAT'S PART
OF WHAT THE TAX SUPPORT DOES.
AND THEN AT THE STATEWIDE
HOMELESS CONFERENCE, WE BRING
THE LEA TOGETHER TO TALK ABOUT
THOSE TYPE OF THINGS AND TO
LEARN ABOUT THOSE THINGS. AND
THEN THAT'S ALSO SHARED ACROSS
THE VARIOUS COUNTIES. AND SO THE
HEAT TAX SUPPORT WITH THAT
REGIONAL APPROACH, AS YOU
MENTIONED. SO THEN THAT WAY THE
COMMUNITY CAN SEE WHAT IS NEEDED
AND THEN THEY CAN BOLSTER THAT.
AND THEN OF COURSE THE HOMELESS
INNOVATIVE PROGRAMS TOOLKIT IS
SOMETHING THAT WE ALSO SUPPORT.
I KNOW THAT MY TEAM HAS DONE A
VERY EFFECTIVE JOB AT UC
BERKELEY, WHERE WE'VE HOSTED
SOME MEETINGS AND THEN THE
HOMELESS INNOVATION PROGRAMS
HAVE BEEN ABLE TO SHOWCASE THE
WORK THEY'RE DOING AND GIVES
IDEAS TO THE OTHER LEAS. AND
THEN WITH THE FEDERAL MONEY,
THAT'S RELATED TO HOMELESS
CHILDREN AND YOUTH IS THAT,
GOING TO BE ABLE TO BE OBLIGATED
AND EXPENDED SO THAT IT'S ALL
USED WITHIN THE TIME FRAMES AND
MONEY WITH THIS INCREDIBLE NEED
DOESN'T GO BACK? YEAH YES. IF
I'M UNDERSTANDING YOUR QUESTION
CORRECTLY, THE LAS HAVE THE
MONIES. AND SO WHAT OUR TEAM
DOES IS WE KNOW THE MONIES THAT
THEY'VE EXPENDED. AND SO THE
MONIES THAT ARE REMAINING ARE
OBLIGATED AND THEY ARE GOING TO
BE EXPENDED. OKAY. AND THEN
OVERALL AND IT'S SIMILAR TO THE
PREVIOUS ITEM OVERALL. WELL,
IT'S THIS MIX OF FUNDING
SOURCES, DIFFERENT POTS FROM THE
FEDS, WHETHER OR NOT THE STATE
DOES SOME WHETHER OR NOT PEOPLE
DISTRICTS DIP INTO THEIR, THEIR
OWN GENERAL FUNDS. IS THERE ANY
GUIDANCE OR PRESSURE FROM THE
STATE ON HOW TO MIX THESE ALL
TOGETHER AND MAKE SURE THAT THE
ISSUES ARE ADDRESSED? I WOULDN'T
SAY PRESSURE. I WOULD SAY
GUIDANCE, LIKE WE'LL PROVIDE
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE ON HOW TO
DO THAT, BRAIDING FUNDS AND
THINGS OF THAT NATURE. THE MY
TEAM DOES A LOT OF TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE AND WEBINARS AND THEN
WORKING WITH THE HEAT TAX,
REALLY TRYING TO SUPPORT SCHOOL
DISTRICTS ON HOW TO EXPEND THOSE
FUNDS SO THAT THEY CAN GET THE
BEST USE OF THOSE MONIES. AND,
IS THERE ANY ADDED COMMENT ON
THOSE QUESTIONS FROM EITHER THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE OR THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST? SURE.
MELISSA NG WITH THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE. SO THAT IS KIND OF
THE PURPOSE OF THE TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE THAT WE'RE PROPOSING
FOR AS PART OF GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
THAT WE ARE HAVING THE HEAT TAX
MAY TAKE A MORE PROACTIVE ROLE
IN LOOKING AT EXISTING FUNDING
STREAMS. SO THEY CAN HELP LEAS
KIND OF, YOU KNOW, BRAID THESE
DIFFERENT FUND SOURCES TOGETHER,
YOU KNOW, ESPECIALLY WITH THE
LCFF, YOU KNOW, THESE STUDENTS
ARE GENERATING YOU KNOW,
POSSIBLY SUPPLEMENTAL AND
CONCENTRATION FUNDING. AND WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THIS
FUNDING IS BEING USED TOWARDS
THOSE STUDENTS AND THE UNIQUE
CHALLENGES THAT THEY FACE. OKAY.
ANYTHING FROM THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST, NO. MR. CHAIR, THANK
YOU. I KNOW, SENATOR WILK, YOU
DIDN'T HEAR JUST THE VERY FIRST
PART OF THIS, BUT I WONDERED IF
YOU HAD ANY QUESTIONS. OKAY, I
KNOW YOU'RE GOOD, BUT I WONDERED
IF YOU HAD QUESTIONS. YEAH OKAY.
WELL. THANK YOU. WELL, THEN,
THIS I APPRECIATE THE
ADMONITION, BUT I APPRECIATE ALL
THE WORK. THAT'S BEING DONE. AND
I THINK AS WE MOVE TOWARD THE
REVISED BUDGET IN MAY AND TYING
IT DOWN, WE'LL REALLY HOPE
THERE'S SOME WAY TO ADDRESS
THESE NEEDS BECAUSE IT IS REALLY
POWERFUL OVER THE FACT THAT THIS
EXISTS AS AN ISSUE. AS I SAY,
YOU DON'T. WE'LL HAVE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES NEXT WEEK AND I WAS A
COMMUNITY COLLEGE TRUSTEE, AND I
HAVEN'T BEEN ON THE BOARD IN 22
YEARS, AND I NEVER HEARD ABOUT
AN UNSHELTERED COMMUNITY COLLEGE
PERSON. IT WAS THE COMMUNITY.
PEOPLE HAD THEIR HOMES, THEY
WERE COMING OUT OF THE
COMMUNITY. AND NOW I ASK AND
IT'S I GET THE ANSWER, THAT
BETWEEN 1 AND 4% OF THE STUDENT
BODY IS UNSHELTERED. AND THEN
THERE'S A DISTINCT LAYER ABOVE
THAT AND WHERE THERE'S HOUSING
INSECURITY. AND SO, I THINK IT'S
REALLY DRAMATIC IN K THROUGH 12.
AND I JUST HOPE THAT IN THE
MIDST OF ALL THE FISCAL
PRESSURES, WE CAN FIGURE OUT HOW
TO CONTINUE TO ADDRESS THAT. SO
THANK YOU, FOR BEING HERE TODAY.
WE APPRECIATE THIS VERY MUCH.
AND WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON TO
WHAT I THINK IS PROBABLY THE
ITEM THAT WILL HAVE THE MOST,
PARTICIPATION ISSUE THREE
NUTRITION. AND WE WILL STILL
CONTINUE WITH MELISSA NG FROM
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. KIM
FRENZEL FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION, AND THEN SARAH CORTEZ
FROM THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE. AND I KNOW WE HAVE THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST REPORT FROM
FEBRUARY THAT THAT HAD A REPORT
ON THIS. AND SO LET ME JUST MAKE
A BRIEF COMMENT HEADING INTO
THIS. AND THAT IS, IS THAT I
THINK THE LEGISLATURE IN THE
LAST FEW YEARS HAS REALLY BEEN
COMMITTED TO UNIVERSAL SCHOOL
MEALS, AND THERE ARE CERTAIN
THINGS ABOUT THIS THAT ARE
COUNTERINTUITIVE, BECAUSE IT'S
ALWAYS TEMPTING TO SQUEEZE EVERY
LAST DOLLAR OUT OF EVERYWHERE,
WHICH ACTUALLY IS THE SUBJECT OF
THIS HEARING. BUT WHEN YOU HAVE
UNIVERSAL ONE THING WE FOUND IN
PLACES THAT HAVE DONE THIS IS
THAT IT REMOVES THE STIGMA.
THERE WAS ALWAYS A FOR KIDS THAT
HAD FREE AND REDUCED MEALS, A
LOT OF TIMES THAT WAS CALLED OUT
IN PLACES THAT THAT THERE WAS A
SORT OF STIGMA OR
UNCOMFORTABILITY ABOUT IT. AND
WHEN THERE'S SORT OF A UNIVERSAL
TO IT, THAT IN SOME PLACES HAS
STARTED TO FALL AWAY SO THAT IS
REALLY SIGNIFICANT. AND THEN THE
COMPLEXITY IS, IS THAT WE HAVE
THESE OVERLAPPING FEDERAL
FUNDING SOURCES THAT, MIGHT NOT
HELP LEAD TO COST CONTROL AND
HOW IT'S DONE AND MIGHT HAVE
SOME DIFFERENT REQUIREMENTS. AND
SO WE'RE TRYING TO FIGURE OUT
HOW TO BE UNIVERSAL BEALL, HOW
TO MAXIMIZE EVERY DOLLAR, HOW TO
CONTROL COSTS, HOW TO REMOVE THE
STIGMA. AND AS YOU'LL SEE IN THE
LENGTHY STAFF REPORT, THOSE
THINGS SEEM TO BE IN CONFLICT.
AND SO I THINK THAT'S THE NATURE
OF OUR DISCUSSION IS UNDERSTAND
WHAT'S HAPPENING, SORT OF HOW
WE'RE GOING AGAINST WHAT THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE GOVERNOR
HAVE WANTED AND WHERE IN A TIME
OF FISCAL DIFFICULTIES DO WE GO
WITH THOSE GOALS. SO THAT IS
SORT OF NORMALLY THAT WAS THE
SPEECH I WOULD HAVE GIVEN AT THE
END AFTER I HEARD YOU ALL TALK,
BUT I THOUGHT IT WOULD SET THE
TABLE FOR THIS. AND SO WE'LL GO
IN THE ORDER THAT I MENTIONED
PEOPLE AND START WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. THANK
YOU. MELISSA NG WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. I'LL
PROVIDE AN OVERVIEW OF THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSAL
RELATED TO CHILD NUTRITION. THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET INCLUDES A ONE
TIME BACKFILL OF 65 MILLION
PROPOSITION 98 GENERAL FUND IN
THE CURRENT YEAR TO COVER AN
ANTICIPATED SHORTFALL BASED ON
NEW PROJECTIONS AND ACTUAL MEAL
COUNTS THROUGH AUGUST 2023. PART
OF THIS SHORTFALL IS ATTRIBUTED
TO CURRENT YEAR FUNDING BEING
USED TO COVER PAST YEAR MEAL
REIMBURSEMENT. FINANCE PROVIDED
AUTHORITY FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION TO UTILIZE UP TO 14
MILLION IN CURRENT YEAR FUNDS TO
COVER PAST YEAR MEAL
REIMBURSEMENT CLAIMS. AS OF
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET, THE
DEPARTMENT HAD USED 12 MILLION
OF THE AUTHORIZED 14 MILLION.
THE SHORTFALL IN THE PAST YEAR
WAS DUE TO 2223 ACTUALS, COMING
IN APPROXIMATELY 17.7 MILLION
MEALS, HIGHER THAN MAY REVISE
ESTIMATES, REPRESENTING ABOUT
1.4% HIGHER LUNCH MEAL COUNTS
AND 3.6% HIGHER BREAKFAST MEAL
COUNTS THAN ORIGINALLY PROJECTED
FOR BUDGET YEAR. THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET ALSO INCLUDES AN INCREASE
OF 122.2 MILLION PROPOSITION 98
GENERAL FUND TO FULLY FUND THE
ANTICIPATED GROWTH IN UNIVERSAL
MEALS IN 2425, BASED ON SERVING
A PROJECTED 848 MILLION MEALS
AND INCLUDING THE ESTIMATED
INCREASE IN FEDERAL
REIMBURSEMENT RATES, WHICH
RESULTS IN CHANGES TO THE STATE
PORTION OF THE REDUCED PRICE AND
PAID MEAL CATEGORIES. THIS
ESTIMATE ASSUMES A 1% INCREASE
IN LUNCH MEAL COUNTS AND 3%
INCREASE IN BREAKFAST MEAL
COUNTS, FOR AN INCREASE OF 17
MILLION ADDITIONAL MEALS OR
OVERALL 2% INCREASE TO THE
UNIVERSAL MEALS PROGRAM. OVER
THE 2223 MEAL COUNTS, WE ASSUME
THERE WILL BE A CONTINUED GROWTH
IN THE SHORT TIME BEFORE
LEVELING OFF WITH ANTICIPATED
GROWTH DRIVERS, INCLUDING THE
CONTINUED RAMP UP OF BREAKFAST
PROGRAMS SINCE PRIOR TO
UNIVERSAL MEALS MANDATE NOT ALL
SCHOOLS OFFERED BREAKFAST. ALSO,
INCREASING AWARENESS OF
UNIVERSAL MEALS IN GENERAL AND
THEN ALSO THE INCREASING QUALITY
AND VARIETY OF MEAL OFFERINGS.
DUE TO RECENT INVESTMENTS IN
BOTH THE KITCHEN INFRASTRUCTURE
AND FRESHLY PREPARED MEALS, THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET INCLUDES AN
INCREASE OF 13.447 MILLION
PROPOSITION 98 GENERAL FUND TO
REFLECT A 0.76% COST OF LIVING
ADJUSTMENT, BRINGING THE STATE
REIMBURSEMENT RATE FROM 0.968
$0.06 TO 0.976 $0.00. THIS WOULD
BRING THE TOTAL INCREASE FOR THE
NUTRITION PROGRAM TO 135.677
MILLION, FOR BOTH GROWTH AND
COST OF LIVING ADJUSTMENT IN THE
BUDGET YEAR, FOR A TOTAL OF
1.783 BILLION. FOR THIS PROGRAM.
THAT CONCLUDES MY REMARKS, AND
I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS AT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THEN
WE'LL GO TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION. WELCOME TO THE
COMMITTEE. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING, MR. CHAIR, AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS, KIM FRENZEL
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION, ON BEHALF OF STATE
SUPERINTENDENT OF PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION TONY THURMOND. AND I
APPRECIATE HAVE TO PULL THE
MICROPHONE A LITTLE CLOSER TO
YOU. THERE YOU GO. ALL RIGHT.
THERE YOU GO. I APPRECIATE YOUR
OPENING REMARKS. AND IT
CERTAINLY FOOD IS VERY
COMPLICATED AND MEALS AND ACCESS
IS INCREDIBLY COMPLICATED. BUT
REDUCING STIGMA IS INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT FOR OUR 5.8 MILLION
PUBLIC SCHOOL STUDENTS. SO I'M
GOING TO TALK MAINLY ABOUT THE
WHY. AND THEN I ALSO WILL
ADDRESS SOME OF WHAT WE ARE
DOING TO HELP ENSURE THAT WE ARE
TRYING TO MAXIMIZE SIZE AS MUCH
OF THE FEDERAL MEAL
REIMBURSEMENT AS POSSIBLE FOR
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. SO
UNIVERSAL MEALS IS ABSOLUTELY
SOUND EDUCATIONAL AND PUBLIC
HEALTH POLICY FOR OUR PUBLIC
SCHOOL STUDENTS, AND IT OFFERS
GREATER ACCESS AND EQUITY TO
HEALTHY MEALS DURING THE SCHOOL
DAY. AND WE HAVE RESEARCH THAT
CONFIRMS THAT FROM ACROSS THE
NATION ON THE VALUE AND THE
EFFICACY OF UNIVERSAL MEALS
PROGRAM, A STRONG UNIVERSAL
MEALS PROGRAM SUPPORTS THE
SOCIAL EMOTIONAL WELL-BEING,
REDUCES THE STIGMA, REDUCES MEAL
DEBT FOR OUR SCHOOL DISTRICTS,
AND IMPROVES THE OVERALL HEALTH
FOR ALL STUDENTS. SCHOOL MEALS
IS AN ESSENTIAL COMPONENT OF THE
WHOLE CHILD APPROACH. QUALITY
EDUCATION, TRANSFORMING OUR
CALIFORNIA SCHOOLS, AND
IMPROVING ACADEMIC ACHIEVEMENT.
AND WE KNOW AND WE HEARD IN THE
LAST PANEL FAR TOO MANY STUDENTS
DO NOT HAVE CONSISTENT ACCESS TO
ADEQUATE NUTRITION OR ABLE TO
MEET THEIR BASIC FOOD NEEDS. AND
A SCHOOL MEALS PROGRAM ARE MANY
TIMES THE HEALTHIEST MEALS THAT
FAR TOO MANY OF OUR STUDENTS ARE
RECEIVING. BASED ON A THIRD
PARTY ANALYSIS SPONSORED BY NO
KID HUNGRY. ON AVERAGE, STUDENTS
ACROSS ALL ECONOMIC LEVELS WHO
ARE EATING SCHOOL BREAKFAST
ACHIEVE 17.5% HIGHER SCORES ON
STANDARDIZED MATH TEST AND
ATTEND ONE AND A HALF MORE DAYS
OF SCHOOL DURING THE SCHOOL
YEAR, A FULLY FUNDED CALIFORNIA
UNIVERSAL MEALS PROGRAM IS
FOUNDATIONAL, SO ALL STUDENTS
HAVE THE ABILITY TO PARTAKE IN A
SCHOOL BREAKFAST AND A SCHOOL
LUNCH WITH DIGNITY AND NO
SHAMING, REGARDLESS OF THEIR
INCOME. AND I WANT TO STRESS
THIS IS INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA DUE TO
OUR HIGH COST OF LIVING COMPARED
TO THE REST OF THE NATION,
BECAUSE THE FEDERAL MEAL
PROGRAMS, THE INCOME THRESHOLDS
ARE CONSISTENT ACROSS ALL 48
STATES AND TERRITORIES, WITH THE
EXCEPTION OF ALASKA AND HAWAII.
THERE IS NO REGIONAL INDEXING.
WHEN THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT SETS
THE FEDERAL POVERTY LEVELS THAT
MAKE A CHILD EITHER INCOME
ELIGIBLE FOR THE PAID RATE, THE
REDUCED PRICE RATE, OR THE FREE
RATE. AND TO KIND OF PUT THIS IN
PERSPECTIVE, THEY JUST RELEASED
THE INCOME GUIDELINES FOR THE
UPCOMING SCHOOL YEAR. SO TO
ILLUSTRATE THIS OF A FAMILY OF
THREE MAKES OVER $47,767
ANNUALLY. THAT'S JUST $919
WEEKLY FOR THAT FAMILY OF THREE,
REGARDLESS IF THEY LIVE IN
CALIFORNIA OR IN IOWA, THEY
WOULD NOT BE INCOME ELIGIBLE FOR
FREE OR REDUCED PRICE MEALS.
THEY WOULD BE CONSIDERED PAID.
AND IF WE DID NOT HAVE
CALIFORNIA UNIVERSAL MEALS, THEY
WOULD NEED TO PAY FOR THEIR
STUDENTS MEALS. THE CALIFORNIA
BUDGET OF POLICY CENTER, OF
RELEASED A REPORT AND BASED ON
2022 DATA, 44% OF THE FOOD
INSECURE FAMILIES IN CALIFORNIA
HAD INCOMES ABOVE THE FEDERAL
POVERTY LEVEL. THAT WOULD MAKE
THEIR THEIR CHILD QUALIFY FOR A
REDUCED PRICE MEAL. FOOD
INSECURITY CROSSES ALL THREE
INCOME ELIGIBILITY CATEGORIES
FOR OUR MEAL PROGRAMS. OUR
FAMILIES DEPEND ON CALIFORNIA
UNIVERSAL MEALS AS PART OF THEIR
CHILD'S EDUCATION, AND OUR
PARTICIPATION NUMBERS REFLECT
THAT. AND YOU HEARD THE
INVESTMENTS THAT WE'RE MAKING
AND THE INCREASE IN
PARTICIPATION PRIOR TO THE
PANDEMIC IN 2018, OUR SCHOOLS
SERVED OVER OVER 822 MILLION
SCHOOL MEALS, AND THE 2223 YEAR
SCHOOLS SERVED MORE THAN 845
BREAKFAST AND LUNCH AND FOR THIS
FEDERAL FOR THIS FISCAL YEAR,
2223, WE ARE PROJECTING THAT
ABOUT EIGHT 894 MILLION SCHOOL
MEALS WILL BE SERVED. BUT
CENTRAL TO BEING ABLE TO PROVIDE
THESE MEALS IS THAT WE HAVE
PREDICTABLE, RELIABLE AND FULL
STATE MEAL REIMBURSEMENT FOR OUR
SCHOOLS. THAT IS. SO THERE'S NO
PRORATION AND THAT WE HAVE THE
ABILITY TO AUGMENT THE AUTHORITY
FOR ADDITIONAL FUNDS IF NEEDED,
SO SCHOOLS CAN HAVE CONFIDENCE
THAT THEY'RE ABLE TO PROVIDE
THESE MEALS, NOT FULLY FUNDING
SCHOOLS FOR UNIVERSAL MEALS IS
DETRIMENTAL TO THEIR FINANCIAL
VIABILITY OF NOT JUST THEIR
CAFETERIA FUND, BUT ALSO THEIR
DISTRICT'S GENERAL FUND, WHICH
IS REALLY, TRULY NEEDED FOR
OTHER THINGS LIKE CLASSROOM
SERVICES AND EDUCATIONAL
SERVICES AND RESOURCES. REYES
THE INTENT OF THE STATE MEAL
REIMBURSEMENT IS TO ENSURE THAT
LOCAL EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES ARE
FINANCIALLY ABLE TO SERVE
HEALTHIER, MORE FRESHLY PREPARED
, CULTURALLY RELEVANT MEALS THAT
MEET THE FEDERAL MEAL STANDARDS.
AND UNFORTUNATELY, WE KNOW THAT
OUR OUR SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND
THEIR FOOD SERVICE DEPARTMENTS
HAVE ALWAYS OPERATED ON
EXTREMELY TIGHT BUDGETS. AND
THIS IS JUST EXACERBATED
RECENTLY WITH, YOU KNOW, WITH
INFLATION, WITH, HIGHER FOOD
COSTS, STAFFING RATES, AND ALSO
AS WELL AS STAFFING VACANCIES,
THESE CONTINUE TO REALLY BE
STRONG PRESSURE POINTS FOR OUR
MEAL PROGRAMS. AND A RECENT
NATIONAL SURVEY BY THE SCHOOL
NUTRITION ASSOCIATION REPORTED
THAT SERIOUS TO MODERATE
CONCERNS REGARDING THE FINANCIAL
STABILITY OF SCHOOL NUTRITION
PROGRAMS IS VERY, VERY PREVALENT
AND THIS CONCERN WAS MOST
CONCENTRATED IN THE WESTERN
STATES. AND WE KNOW THIS IS TRUE
FOR CALIFORNIA AS WELL, BECAUSE
28% OF OUR PUBLIC SCHOOLS AND
42% OF THE CHARTER SCHOOLS THAT
ARE OPERATING THE NATIONAL
SCHOOL LUNCH SCHOOL BREAKFAST
PROGRAM ARE ENCROACHING ON THEIR
DISTRICT'S GENERAL FUND TO
SUPPORT THEIR MEAL OPERATIONS.
AND THIS WILL CONTINUE TO BE
PROBLEMATIC AS MANY OF THE VERY
GENEROUS AND WONDERFUL STATE ONE
TIME GRANTS, SUCH AS THE KITCHEN
AND KITCHEN INFRASTRUCTURE AND
TRAINING FUNDS, AND THE LOCAL
SCHOOL FOODS BEST PRACTICES AS
THOSE START TO SUNSET, WE'RE
GOING TO SEE MORE OF THE
ENCROACHMENT BY OUR SCHOOL FOOD
SERVICE DEPARTMENTS. IF FOR ANY
REASON UNIVERSAL MEALS IS
PRORATED OR REDUCED, SUSTAINING
UNIVERSAL MEALS AND THE STATE
FUNDING IS CRITICAL, AS IS GOOD
STEWARDSHIP AND SOLID POLICY. WE
DO RECOGNIZE THAT. SO THERE'S
NOT ONE SINGULAR I AM WRAPPING
UP. THERE'S NOT ONE SINGULAR,
SOLUTION TO MAXIMIZE THE FEDERAL
REIMBURSEMENTS. IT WILL CONTINUE
TO TAKE SEVERAL STRATEGIES, BUT
IN STARTING IN THE NEW SCHOOL
YEAR, THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION WILL BE IMPLEMENTING A
NEW ENHANCED DIRECT
CERTIFICATION MATCHING PROCESS
TO ALLOW FOR MORE, PROBABILISTIC
MATCHING OR FUZZY MATCHING SO
THAT WE CAN MAKE SURE THAT WE
HAVE WE'RE IDENTIFYING MORE
CHILDREN THAT ARE CATEGORICALLY
ELIGIBLE FOR THE PROGRAMS. THIS
STRATEGY, ALONG WITH REALLY
CONTINUING TO WORK WITH OUR
SCHOOLS ON ON THEIR LOCAL DIRECT
SEARCH, SEARCH, DIRECT
CERTIFICATION MATCH THROUGH THE
LOCAL COUNTY SOCIAL SERVICES
OFFICE, AGAIN WILL HELP INCREASE
THOSE STUDENTS THAT ARE BEING
IDENTIFIED AS CATEGORICALLY
ELIGIBLE AND WILL HELP US TO
BETTER MAXIMIZE THE FEDERAL
REIMBURSEMENT. WE ARE CONTINUING
OUR LONG STANDING PRACTICE OF
STRONG TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE,
TRAINING, RESOURCES,
COMMUNICATIONS, SHARING OF BEST
PRACTICES AND AROUND DIRECTLY
DIRECT CERTIFICATION AND HOW
BEST TO MAXIMIZE COMMUNITY
ELIGIBILITY AND OTHER FEDERAL
PROVISIONS. AND LIKEWISE, THERE
ARE SOME POLICY DECISIONS THAT
WE THAT WE COLLECTIVELY CAN MAKE
UNDER THE FEDERAL RULE DIRECT
CERTIFICATION. THERE'S ONLY
THREE TIME A YEAR REQUIREMENT TO
DO THEIR MATCH, AND WE STRONGLY
ENCOURAGE SCHOOLS TO DO THAT ON
A MONTHLY BASIS. THAT COULD BE A
REQUIREMENT THAT WE CONSIDER. SO
FINALLY, WE, YEAH, I ALSO DON'T
WANT TO LOSE SIGHT OF THE
IMPORTANCE OF ENSURING THAT
STUDENTS HAVE ADEQUATE TIME TO
EAT THEIR HEALTHY SCHOOL MEALS.
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THAT'S
IN THE FOREFRONT AS WELL. SO IN
CLOSING, AS A FIRST STATE IN THE
NATION TO IMPLEMENT UNIVERSAL
MEALS, WE HAVE TAKEN BOLD STEPS
TO ESTABLISH GREATER EQUITY IN
OUR SCHOOL MEAL PROGRAMS THAT
BENEFIT ALL STUDENTS AND THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION COULD
NOT HAVE DONE IT ALONE. WE HAVE
SO MANY STRONG PARTNERS AND
COMMUNITY ADVOCATES OUT THERE
HELPING US TO BE VERY GOOD
THOUGHT PARTNERS AND TO BE GOOD
STEWARDS AND PROTECTING THIS
PROGRAM. SO TOGETHER WE ARE
INVESTING IN EVERY STUDENT SO
THAT THEY ALL ARE BETTER
EQUIPPED TO REACH THEIR FULL
ACADEMIC POTENTIAL THROUGH
CONSISTENT, NUTRITIOUS MEALS
EACH SCHOOL DAY. THANK YOU. THAT
CONCLUDES MY VERY LONG
TESTIMONY, AND I'M HAPPY TO
ANSWER QUESTIONS AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THEN WE'LL MOVE TO THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST. GOOD
MORNING, SARAH CORTEZ. ELIO
GIVEN THE BUDGET CONDITION AND
THE COST PRESSURES WITHIN THE
SCHOOL NUTRITION PROGRAM, OUR
SCHOOL NUTRITION ANALYSIS
PROVIDES OPTIONS TO CONTAIN
FUTURE COST GROWTH. AND I WANT
TO EMPHASIZE THAT THIS IS A MENU
OF OPTIONS THAT THE LEGISLATURE
CAN CHOOSE FROM. IF IT DECIDES
THIS IS AN AREA THAT COSTS NEED
TO BE CONTAINED BECAUSE OF
PROJECTED GROWTH IN THE
NUTRITION PROGRAM AND AVAILABLE
FUNDING, NONE OF THESE OPTIONS
WE PROVIDE IN OUR ANALYSIS WOULD
CHANGE THE REQUIREMENT FOR
PUBLIC SCHOOLS TO OFFER FREE
MEALS TO ALL THEIR STUDENTS. SO
IN OUR VIEW, THIS MAINTAINS
UNIVERSAL MEALS. NOW, BEFORE I
WALK THROUGH THE DIFFERENT
OPTIONS WE PUT, I WANT TO SPEND
A FEW MINUTES DISCUSSING HOW THE
STATE RATES HAVE CHANGED FOR
SCHOOL NUTRITION PROGRAMS
BECAUSE OF TWO ACTIONS. ONE WAS
IMPLEMENTING UNIVERSAL MEALS AND
THE OTHER WAS PROVIDING
DISCRETIONARY, A DISCRETIONARY
RATE INCREASE, THE SERGEANT
PROVIDED YOU WITH OUR
PROPOSITION 98 REPORT THAT LOOKS
LIKE THIS. IN THIS REPORT,
THERE'S A GREEN TAB THAT TURNS
YOU TO PAGE 24 OF OUR ANALYSIS,
FIGURE 11 IS THE FIGURE I WANT
TO WALK THROUGH BECAUSE IT SHOWS
HOW RATES WORK UNDER UNIVERSAL
MEALS. ALL THE BARS ARE THE SAME
HEIGHT. SO A SCHOOL RECEIVES THE
SAME AMOUNT PER MEAL, REGARDLESS
IF IT'S SERVED TO A STUDENT
ELIGIBLE FOR FREE, REDUCED OR
PAID. YOU CAN SEE THAT THE FREE
FOR THAT A FREE MEAL. THE BULK
OF THE FUNDS THAT MAKE UP THE
RATE THAT MAKE UP THE RATE THE
SCHOOL RECEIVES ARE FEDERAL
FUNDS WITH A SMALL SHARE OF
STATE FUNDS, WHERE A PAID MEAL
THAT'S FLIPPED THE BULK OF THE
FUNDS THAT A MEAL FOR THE MEAL
IS STATE FUNDS WITH A SMALL
SHARE OF FEDERAL FUNDS PRIOR TO
UNIVERSAL MEAL, THE STATE
PROVIDED A FLAT RATE OF $0.25,
AND THAT WAS ONLY PROVIDED FOR
FREE AND REDUCED MEALS. PAID
MEALS DID NOT RECEIVE ANY STATE
FUNDS. SO FIGURE 12 OF OUR OF
OUR REPORT SHOWS THE HISTORICAL
RATE GOING BACK TO 20 1819. IN
2223, THERE WAS A SIGNIFICANT
DISCRETIONARY RATE INCREASE OF
$0.63 PER MEAL THAT WAS
PROVIDED. SO THAT'S WHY YOU SEE
IN 2223 ON FIGURE 12 THAT THOSE
BROWN BARS JUMP UP QUITE A BIT,
AND THEN YOU SEE THIS NEW BLUE
BAR REFLECTING THAT THE STATE
FOR THE FIRST TIME PROVIDED
FUNDS FOR PAID MEALS IN
ACCORDANCE TO THE NEWLY
ESTABLISHED REIMBURSEMENT SYSTEM
UNDER UNIVERSAL SCHOOL MEALS. SO
NOW WITH THAT BACKGROUND, I'LL
WALK THROUGH THE THREE OPTIONS
WE PUT FORTH IN OUR IN OUR
ANALYSIS, THE FIRST OPTION IS TO
SET THE NUTRITION RATE LOWER.
THERE ARE TWO WAYS TO REDUCE THE
RATE. THE FIRST IS ACROSS THE
BOARD REDUCTION. GOING BACK TO
OUR FIGURE 11. THIS KEEPS ALL
THE BARS THE SAME HEIGHT. IT'S
JUST LOWERING THEM ALL WITH WITH
THE STATE AMOUNT. OR ANOTHER
OPTION IS TAKING A TARGETED
APPROACH, SUCH AS REDUCING THE
PAID CONTRIBUTION. AS YOU CAN
SEE IN THIS FIGURE, THE PAID BAR
REQUIRES THE MOST STATE FUNDS,
SO THAT. SO THAT WOULD BE
ANOTHER OPTION THERE. THE PAID
BAR WOULD BE LOWER. THE FREE AND
REDUCED PRICE WOULD REMAIN THE
SAME HEIGHT. THE SECOND OPTION
WE LAY OUT IS REVISITING THE
APPROACH TO COLA. SO LOOKING
BACK AT OUR FIGURE 11, LET'S
JUST LOOK AT THE FREE BAR FOR A
SECOND. THE DARK PIECE OF THE
BAR IS GROWN ANNUALLY BY THE
STATE K-12. COLA GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET ASSUMES A 0.76, AND THE
TEAL BAR IS GROWN BY THE FEDERAL
COLA SET BY THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT, THAT WILL BE
PROVIDED WITH FEDERAL FUNDS.
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET ASSUMES A 5.5%
INCREASE UNDER THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET. THE COMBINED STATE AND
STATE AND FEDERAL CONTRIBUTION
GROWS 4.7. SO THAT'S THE
INCREASE THAT THAT SCHOOLS WOULD
RECEIVE, WHICH IS MUCH HIGHER
THAN THE 0.76% PRESUMED ASSUMED
IN THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET FOR THE
REST OF K-12 PROGRAMS. THE
GROWTH IN THE FEDERAL COLA
RESULTS IN THE STATE
CONTRIBUTION TO THE PAID RATE
BEYOND THE 0.7 6% STATE COLA, AS
WELL THE STATE SHARE OF THE PAID
RATE IS ASSUMED TO GROW 6.6%
UNDER GOVERNOR'S BUDGET BECAUSE
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT PROVIDES
BECAUSE BECAUSE THE INCREASE THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT PROVIDES TO
THE FREE RATE AND HOW OUR
REIMBURSEMENT SYSTEM IS
STRUCTURED. SO THE STATE
APPROACH FOR THE COLA, THE STATE
COULD APPROACH THE COLA
DIFFERENTLY FOR SCHOOL
NUTRITION. THE FIRST APPROACH IS
TO NO LONGER PROVIDE A FEDERAL
COLA TO THE PAID RATE, AND THIS
WOULD MEAN THE COMBINED FREE AND
PAID RATE WOULD NO LONGER GROW
AT THE SAME PACE. THE SECOND
APPROACH IS TO SUSPEND THE
AUTOMATIC COLA ADJUSTMENT AND
JUST DECIDE ON THE INFLATIONARY
ADJUSTMENT FACTOR ANNUALLY. THE
THIRD OPTION WE LAY OUT IS
SUSPEND THE ADMINISTRATIVE
AUGMENTATION AUTHORITY IN 2223.
THE BUDGET INCLUDED PROVISIONAL
LANGUAGE THAT REQUIRES
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE TO AUGMENT
THE APPROPRIATION FOR SCHOOL
NUTRITION. IF EXPENDITURES ARE
PROJECTED TO EXCEED THE AMOUNT
AVAILABLE. IF THE LEGISLATURE
SUSPENDED THIS LANGUAGE, IT
WOULD RETURN SCHOOL NUTRITION
FUNDING TO HOW IT WORKED PRIOR
TO 2223, WHERE IF THERE WASN'T
ENOUGH FUNDING FOR SCHOOL
NUTRITION PROVIDED IN THE ANNUAL
BUDGET, THE LEGISLATURE COULD
EITHER PROVIDE AN ADDITIONAL
AUGMENTATION OR PRORATE THE
STATE MILL RATE SO SPENDING THIS
LANGUAGE ALLOWS THE LEGISLATURE
TO CONSIDER INCREASES IN SCHOOL
NUTRITION, ALONG WITH OTHER
PRIORITIES WITHIN K-12 EDUCATION
. AND THE LAST THING I'LL
DISCUSS IS OUR ONLY
RECOMMENDATION. ALL OF
EVERYTHING THAT I TALKED ABOUT
WAS WAS OPTIONS. YOU HAVE BEFORE
YOU. AND THIS RECOMMENDATION IS
ALIGNED WITH TOWARD AN EYE OF
LONG TERME PROGRAM STRUCTURE,
AND IT'S ABOUT THE MANDATORY
PARTICIPATION REQUIREMENT FOR
CEP SCHOOLS. SO THERE'S A
THERE'S NEWLY ELIGIBLE CEP
SCHOOLS STARTING IN 24, 25.
GIVEN A FEDERAL RULE CHANGE WITH
THE FEDERAL THE RULE CHANGE, THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT, TO
IMPLEMENTED AND THE STATE
REQUIRES THAT IF YOU'RE ELIGIBLE
FOR CEP, YOU MUST OPT INTO WHAT
WE REFER TO IN OUR REPORT AS
ALTERNATIVE REIMBURSEMENT
OPTIONS, OR WHAT BETTERLY
REFERRED TO AS THE PROVISIONS.
SO FIGURE TEN OF OUR ANALYSIS ON
PAGE 23 OF YOUR REPORT PROVIDES
A SIDE BY SIDE OF HOW SCHOOL
NUTRITION REIMBURSEMENT
TRADITIONALLY WORKS AND HOW IT
WORKS UNDER CEP, ONE OF THE KEY
REASONS FOR THE MANDATORY
PARTICIPATION REQUIREMENT, THE
STATE MANDATORY PARTICIPATION
REQUIREMENT, I SHOULD SAY, IS TO
MAXIMIZE FEDERAL REIMBURSEMENTS.
AND BASED ON OUR MODELING, CEP
PARTICIPATION FOR NEWLY ELIGIBLE
SCHOOLS DOESN'T ALWAYS MAXIMIZE
FEDERAL REIMBURSEMENT, AMONG THE
NEWLY ELIGIBLE GROUP, ABOUT HALF
OF THEM WOULD. AND THEN HALF OF
THEM, HALF OF THEM WOULD RECEIVE
GREATER FEDERAL REIMBURSEMENT,
AND THEN HALF OF THEM WOULD
RECEIVE LOWER FEDERAL
REIMBURSEMENT, MEANING THE STATE
WOULD HAVE TO MAKE UP THAT
DIFFERENCE UNDER OUR
REIMBURSEMENT STRUCTURE, AN
EXAMPLE THAT WE HIGHLIGHT IN A
REPORT IS A SCHOOL THAT RECEIVED
A FREE THAT RECEIVED THE FREE
AND REDUCED PRICE RATE FOR TWO
THIRDS OF ITS LUNCHES, BUT IT
HAD A PRETTY LOW ISP OF 29. IT
WASN'T ELIGIBLE FOR CEP IN 2223,
BUT IT WOULD BE REQUIRED TO
PARTICIPATE IN 2425, SO UNDER
CEP, IF IT WOULD HAVE BEEN
ELIGIBLE, LESS THAN HALF OF ITS
LUNCHES WOULD HAVE BEEN
REIMBURSED AT THE FREE AND
REDUCED PRICE MEAL. WHERE IT IT
USED TO RECEIVE TWO THIRDS OF
ITS LUNCHES, RESULTING IN
INCREASED STATE COSTS. AND THAT
CONCLUDES MY REMARKS. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. I WAS GOING
TO GIVE SENATOR WILK A FIRST
HAVE AT. BUT WHILE YOUR COMMENTS
ARE FRESH IN OUR MIND, LET ME
ASK A FOLLOW UP BEFORE CHECKING
WITH HIM. AND THAT IS YOU HAVE
OPTIONS THAT YOU JUST MENTIONED
FOR TRYING TO PRESERVE THE
PROVISION OF UNIVERSAL MEALS.
BUT BE ABLE TO CUT COSTS AND IN
CERTAIN WAYS DO DO THOSE OPTIONS
RELY ON ON SCHOOL DISTRICTS
HAVING TO PUT MONEY IN THAT THEY
DON'T PUT IN? BECAUSE WE'RE SORT
OF CAPPING STATE AND FEDERAL BY
WHAT WE'RE DOING AND STILL
REQUIRING THE UNIVERSAL OR THE.
I'M JUST TRYING TO UNDERSTAND.
AND BECAUSE I HAVE A FEELING
THERE'S SOMEBODY THAT PAYS THE
PIPER FOR THAT, AND I'M TRYING
TO UNDERSTAND IF WHETHER IT'S IN
SOME REDUCED SERVICE OR SOMEBODY
ELSE PAYING COSTS, HOW IN YOUR
OPTIONS WOULD THAT FIT. YEAH. SO
THIS SO I THINK IT DEPENDS ON
WHAT OPTION WE'RE TALKING ABOUT.
SO THE FIRST ONE WE LAID OUT IS
JUST PAYING A LOWER PER MEAL
PRICE FOR EACH MEAL THAT WE
SERVE. SO THAT THAT COULD HAVE
THE EFFECT IN DIFFERENT WAYS.
AND HOW AND HOW NUTRITION,
DEPARTMENTS AT, AT SCHOOL
DISTRICTS KIND OF RESPOND. ADD
TO THAT, THE OTHER OPTION IS
JUST CHANGING THE WAY IT GROWS
ON AN ANNUAL BASIS. THAT WAS THE
SECOND OPTION. SO THAT'S GOING
TO THAT'S GOING TO HAVE IMPACTS
IN THE FUTURE, THIS, THIS IDEA
THAT WE'RE KIND OF MATCHING THE
FEDERAL RATE, JUST CERTAINLY
DOESN'T ALIGN WITH KIND OF
GROWTH IN, IN OTHER AREAS THAT
K-12, OTHER K-12 PROGRAMS ARE
ABOUT TO SEE. AND THEN THE OTHER
ANOTHER THE RECOMMENDATION THAT
WE ACTUALLY HAVE, IS JUST
LOOKING AT LIKE, WHAT ARE WE
REQUIRING THAT SCHOOL DISTRICTS
DO WITH THE CEP PARTICIPATION?
IT'S NEW THAT THEY'RE GOING TO
HAVE TO PARTICIPATE BECAUSE OF
OUR STATE MANDATORY
PARTICIPATION REQUIREMENT, SO
THAT THAT'S SOMETHING THAT ISN'T
IN PLACE YET. BUT WE SEE AS
SOMETHING LOOKING INTO THE
FUTURE THAT COULD RESULT IN, IN
STATE COSTS. OKAY. THANK YOU.
LET ME ASK I'M GOING TO DEFER TO
YOU. OKAY COME BACK TO ME IF I
HAVE A FOLLOW UP TO ONE OF YOUR
QUESTIONS. I APPRECIATE THAT, I
WAS GOING TO ASK A COUPLE OF THE
QUESTIONS THAT ARE IN THE AGENDA
PACKET, BUT FIRST, IT JUST IN A
MORE GLOBAL WAY. HOW CAN WE TRY
TO STICK TO OUR COMMITMENT FOR
UNIVERSAL MEALS AND MAXIMIZE
FEDERAL FUNDING? WHAT? AND I
KNOW YOU MENTIONED THAT, BUT
JUST SORT OF DRAWING IT OUT WITH
ALL THREE OF YOU, ARE THERE
SPECIFIC STEPS THAT WE CAN TAKE
AS PART OF THE BUDGET PROCESS TO
DO THAT? THE FINANCE PERSON
LOOKS MILDLY PERPLEXED, LIAISING
WITH DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. SO I
DON'T THINK THERE'S LIKE AN EASY
ANSWER, YOU KNOW, I THINK WE CAN
TRY TO HAVE PROVIDE MORE
GUIDANCE TO SCHOOLS TO TRY TO
COLLECT AS MANY MORE
APPLICATIONS AS WE CAN. SO WE
ARE MAXIMIZING OUR FEDERAL
DRAWDOWN. AND I THINK WE HEARD
FROM MY COLLEAGUE AT THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION HOW
THEY'RE TRYING TO UTILIZE FUZZY
MATCH FOR DIRECT CERTIFICATION.
THÀNH. SO, WE CAN, IDENTIFY
ELIGIBLE STUDENTS EVEN IF WE
DON'T RECEIVE APPLICATIONS. BUT
I THINK THERE'S JUST A CONTINUED
GROWTH IN MEALS. AND I THINK,
YOU KNOW, STUDENTS NEED THESE
MEALS. AND THAT'S WHY WE'RE
SEEING THIS GROWTH, YOU KNOW,
LAO HAS LAID OUT SOME OF THE
OPTIONS THAT WE CAN TAKE IN
ORDER TO KIND OF CONTAIN COSTS.
BUT, YOU KNOW, WITH WITH THE
MANDATE, THE FUNDING THAT WE
DON'T PROVIDE FROM THE STATE,
YOU KNOW, SCHOOLS WILL END UP
HAVING TO TAKE ON THAT BURDEN IF
THEY'RE ALREADY OPERATING ON
KIND OF TIGHT BUDGETS AS IT IS.
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION, KIM
FRENZEL WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION, YEAH, I THINK THERE'S
A FEW OPTIONS. RIGHT. IT'S NOT
GOING TO BE ONE ONE SILVER
LINING THAT WILL SOLVE IT ALL,
CERTAINLY THE FUZZY MATCHING I
THINK WILL ABSOLUTELY HELP. AND
SO WE'RE GOING TO BE ABLE TO
IDENTIFY MORE CHILDREN THAT ARE
ELIGIBLE AT THE FREE RATE. SO
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT WILL BE
PICKING UP THAT THAT PRICE TAG,
WE COULD CERTAINLY CONSIDER
INSTEAD OF ENCOURAGING SCHOOLS
UNDER THE FEDERAL LAW, AGAIN,
AROUND THE MONTHLY MATCHING TO
PULL DOWN THEIR STUDENT DATA TO
SEE WHAT CHILDREN ARE BEING
DIRECTLY CERTIFIED, MAYBE THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA COULD,
COULD, COULD CONSIDER A MONTHLY
REQUIREMENT TO THAT. SO AGAIN,
JUST SO THAT WE FRESH FRESH DATA
AND CONTINUING TO LOOK INTO
MAXIMIZE THOSE MATCHES, I THINK
THERE'S WE CAN CERTAINLY WORK
WITH OUR COUNTERPARTS CGRTS AT
THE LOCAL SOCIAL SERVICES AND
HEALTH DEPARTMENTS AND THE LOCAL
MATCH THAT'S HELPING TO HELP
SCHOOLS DO BETTER MATCHES AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL. WE DON'T WANT JUST
A STATE MATCH OR JUST A LOCAL
MATCH. WE NEED TO USE ALL
AVENUES. SO I THINK WE CAN BUILD
STRONGER PARTNERSHIPS THERE. I
THINK THERE'S CERTAINLY IN ONE
OF THE OPTIONS TO CONSIDER IS
WHEN WE IMPLEMENTED UNIVERSAL
MEALS, AT THAT TIME, THE FEDERAL
THRESHOLD FOR COMMUNITY
ELIGIBILITY WAS AT THE 40%
IDENTIFIED STUDENT PERCENTAGE.
THAT HAS NOW BEEN REDUCED
FEDERALLY DOWN TO THE 25% AT THE
TIME WHEN WE INTRODUCED POLICY
FOR UNIVERSAL MEALS, REQUIRING
THAT THE HIGH POVERTY SCHOOLS
THAT MET THE CURRENT THRESHOLD
FOR COMMUNITY ELIGIBILITY, IT
WAS AT THAT 40. THAT'S NO LONGER
NECESSARILY MAXIMIZING FEDERAL
DOLLARS. SO DO WE NEED TO
REEXAMINE, REEXAMINE THAT AS
WELL? AND THEN WHAT I WILL JUST
SAY IS, AS, AS THANKFULLY, AS WE
GET, YOU KNOW, FURTHER OUT FROM
THE PANDEMIC FAMILIES AND THE
EDUCATION AND, YOU KNOW, MOVING
AWAY FROM NØ REQUIREMENTS FOR
MEAL APPLICATIONS OR DATA
COLLECTION FOR THE MEAL
PROGRAMS, WE'RE GOING TO BE ABLE
TO REEDUCATE OUR FAMILIES ON THE
IMPORTANCE OF UNIVERSAL MEALS
AND THE DATA COLLECTION. AND
REALLY, DO ONE OF YOUR POINTS.
HOW DO WE INCENTIVIZE THIS? IT'S
REALLY MOVING AWAY FROM IT'S A
MEAL APPLICATION OR A MEAL DATA
TO IT'S EDUCATIONAL DATA FOR OUR
FAMILIES THAT WE NEED. SO
WHETHER IT'S FOR TITLE ONE
FUNDING OR, YOU KNOW, INTERNET
SERVICES, LA UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT HAS A BEAUTIFUL
CAMPAIGN. AND IT'S BEEN QUITE
SUCCESSFUL. THEN, IN COLLECTING
THEIR DATA AND IT'S, YOU KNOW,
MORE MORE THAN A MEAL. SO REALLY
JUST REFRAMING THAT NARRATIVE
WITH OUR SCHOOLS AND OUR
COMMUNITIES. THANK YOU. AND
ANYTHING YOU WOULD ADD? YEAH, I
KNOW YOU'VE LAID OUT OPTIONS
ALREADY. YEAH I JUST WANTED TO
PROVIDE SOME ADDITIONAL DATA
THAT ADDS A LITTLE WRINKLE AND
NUANCE TO THIS CONVERSATION. SO
WITHIN YOUR AGENDA AND IN OUR
REPORT, THERE'S FIGURE 15 THAT
SHOWS THAT HIGHER THERE'S A
HIGHER SHARE OF LUNCHES THAT ARE
SERVED IN THE PAID CATEGORY. AND
I LAID OUT HOW THE NUTRITION
REIMBURSEMENTS WORK, WHERE THE
PAID THE PAID MEALS ARE THE MOST
EXPENSIVE FROM THE STATE'S
PERSPECTIVE. BUT THE OTHER LAYER
OF INFORMATION I WANT TO PROVIDE
OVER THIS IS OUR FRPM.
ELIGIBILITY RATES AT THE
STATEWIDE ARE ACTUALLY QUITE
STABLE. SO IN 20 1819, 59.4% OF
STUDENTS WERE ELIGIBLE FOR FREE
AND REDUCED PRICE MEALS IN 2223,
59.9, SO THAT WE HAVE THESE
STABLE ELIGIBILITY K¾T FRPM
ELIGIBILITY RATES. BUT WE ARE
SEEING THIS TREND WHERE THERE
ARE MORE PAID MEALS. SO THOSE
THOSE THINGS I WOULD I WOULD
WHEN SEEING THIS DATA. AT FIRST
GLANCE, I, I GO TO THE SAME
THOUGHT PERSPECTIVE AS I THINK
SOME OF YOU ARE GIVEN THE
QUESTIONS AND THE AGENDA OF WE
NEED TO MAKE SURE WE'RE
MAINTAINING THE ELIGIBILITY OR
INCREASING THE ELIGIBILITY, BUT
OUR RATES OF ELIGIBILITY ARE ARE
STABLE. SO THAT'S JUST A LAYER
OF INFORMATION TO PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL NUANCE TO THIS
CONVERSATION. OKAY. AND I KNOW
THAT, THAT ONE OF THE QUESTIONS
WAS HOW TO INCENTIVIZE FAMILIES
TO SUBMIT THE FEDERAL MEAL
ELIGIBILITY FORMS. AND I KNOW
WE'VE TALKED AROUND THAT, BUT
ANYTHING ON THAT THAT WE HAVEN'T
TALKED ABOUT THAT MIGHT BE HELP
IN DOING THAT. OKAY THEN. AND
LAST CALL, I THINK THE THIS JUST
BRINGS US BACK TO WHERE WE WERE
AT THE BEGINNING OF THE HEARING.
AND IT IT THIS IS A CONVERSATION
THAT NOW NEEDS TO HAPPEN BETWEEN
YOU IN THE NEXT MONTH, BECAUSE
WE WILL WANT TO CONTINUE THE
UNIVERSAL PART. BUT WE WILL WANT
TO BE ABLE TO PAY FOR IT, AND
WE'LL WANT TO BE ABLE TO
MAXIMIZE THE OTHER MONEY WE CAN.
AND UNFORTUNATELY, I WOULD LIKE
TO BE CLEAR FOR SHIFTING THE
COST TO SOMEBODY IN IN HOW WE'RE
DOING THAT IN SOME WAYS, BECAUSE
WE'RE HEARING A LOT FROM SCHOOL
DISTRICTS OF, OF THE FRACTION OF
A PERCENT, YES. IT'S CLOSER TO
TWO THIRDS OF A PERCENT, BUT THE
PERCENT THAT MIGHT BE IN THE
LOCAL CONTROL FUNDING FORMULA
WHEN PEOPLE HAVE CONTRACTS,
INFLATIONS AND OTHER THINGS AND
JAMMING ADDITIONAL COSTS IN THAT
ARE NOT COVERED NOW, IT'S GOING
TO JUST BE VERY, VERY DIFFICULT
IN THIS YEAR. SO AND YET WE HAVE
PRESENTED YOU WITH JUST A
WONDERFULLY IMPOSSIBLE
SITUATION. WE'VE JUST REALLY
WANT TO KEEP THE MEALS GOING AND
SAY FIGURE IT OUT. BUT IT'S LIKE
THERE'S A REALITY IN FIGURING IT
OUT. SO I APPRECIATE THE FACT
THAT THIS HAS BEEN, AIRED IN A
GOOD WAY THAT WE HAVE HEARD THE
OPTIONS AND, AND I THINK WE
UNDERSTAND CLEARLY WHAT'S BEFORE
US. SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH, FOR
PARTICIPATING TODAY. AND WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE ON TO OUR LAST
ISSUE ISSUE FOR PARKS ACCESS.
AND OUR PANELISTS ARE KATIE
LAGOMARSINO FROM THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE, ELIZABETH MCGURK
FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF PARKS AND
RECREATION. AND MICHAEL AL-FARIS
, A RETURN PANELIST FROM THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE.
AND SO WE WILL GO IN THAT ORDER
OF FINANCE, PARKS AND
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST. SO WELCOME
TO THE COMMITTEE. GOOD MORNING.
GOOD MORNING, CHAIR. SENATOR
WILK KATIE LAGOMARSINO WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. ALL
PROVIDE AN OVERVIEW OF OUR STATE
PARKS PASS PROPOSAL. THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSES 2.1
MILLION ONGOING PROP 98 GENERAL
FUND FOR A COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION TO ENABLE FOURTH
GRADERS ATTENDING PUBLIC SCHOOLS
TO ACCESS CALIFORNIA STATE
PARKS. THE CORRESPONDING
STATUTORY LANGUAGE PROPOSES THAT
THE SELECTED COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION CONTRACT WITH THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF PARKS
AND RECREATION AND WILL NOT
RECOVER INDIRECT COSTS ON THESE
FUNDS. THAT CONCLUDES MY
REMARKS. I'M HAPPY TO TAKE
QUESTIONS AT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME. THANK YOU. AND THEN LET ME
WELCOME BACK TO THE LEGISLATURE.
LIZ MCGURK FROM THE DEPARTMENT
OF PARKS AND RECREATION. GOOD TO
SEE YOU. THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR
AND MEMBERS. LIZ MCGURK, CHIEF
DEPUTY DIRECTOR AT THE
DEPARTMENT OF PARKS AND
RECREATION AND AS PART OF THE
GOVERNOR'S OUTDOORS FOR ALL
INITIATIVE IN 2021, THE
DEPARTMENT OF PARKS CREATED THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ADVENTURE PASS.
AND THIS PASS PROVIDES
CALIFORNIA FOURTH GRADERS WITH
FREE DAY USE ACCESS TO 54 STATE
PARKS THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA.
DURING THE FOURTH GRADE SCHOOL
YEAR, AND WE DO THAT FROM
SEPTEMBER THROUGH THE END OF
AUGUST, THE ADVENTURE PASS IS AN
IMPORTANT TOOL TO ASSIST
CALIFORNIA'S EFFORTS TO INCREASE
ACCESS TO OUR NATURAL, CULTURAL,
AND RECREATIONAL RESOURCES BY
INTEGRATING OUTDOOR EXPERIENCES
INTO THE FOURTH GRADE LEARNING,
WE HOPE TO INSPIRE A DEEPER
CONNECTION WITH NATURE AND
INSTILL VALUABLE LESSONS IN
ENVIRONMENTAL STEWARDSHIP AND
CALIFORNIA HISTORY. AS OF APRIL
15TH OVER 57,000 ADVENTURE
PASSES HAVE BEEN DOWNLOADED FOR
THIS CURRENT SCHOOL YEAR.
SPECIFICALLY, OVER 13,000 PASSES
HAVE BEEN DOWNLOADED. THE $2.1
MILLION REQUEST IS REQUESTED
INCLUDES FUNDING FOR STAFF
COSTS, OPERATING EQUIPMENT AND
TRANSPORTATION GRANT PROGRAMS.
AND WE BELIEVE THAT PROVIDING
FREE DAY USE ACCESS TO
CALIFORNIA FOURTH GRADERS WILL
NOT ONLY OPEN DOORS TO OUTDOOR
EXPLORATION, BUT ALSO BREAKS
DOWN BARRIERS THAT MIGHT
OTHERWISE HINDER ACCESS TO THESE
INVALUABLE RESOURCES. AND WITH
THAT, I THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION AND I'M HAPPY TO
TAKE QUESTIONS AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THEN WE'LL GO TO THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST, THANK YOU,
MR. CHAIR, SIMILAR TO OUR
COMMENTS ON ISSUE TWO, WE DON'T
HAVE SPECIFIC RECOMMENDATIONS ON
THE MERITS OF THE PROPOSAL, BUT
JUST REITERATING THE KIND OF THE
BUDGET ISSUE, THE TIGHTNESS OF
THE STATE BUDGET AND COST
PRESSURES THAT, ONGOING PROGRAMS
WOULD, KIND OF ADD AND, WHETHER,
REGARDLESS OF WHETHER OR NOT YOU
APPROVE THIS PROPOSAL, DISTRICTS
COULD USE THEIR LOCAL FUNDS,
SUCH AS LCFF, TO SUPPORT FIELD
TRIPS AND OTHER ACTIVITIES TO
CONNECT STUDENTS WITH PARKS AND
OUTDOOR SPACES, WITH THAT
CONCLUDES MY COMMENTS. HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. BEFORE WE GO TO MY
QUESTION, I JUST HAVE TO COMMENT
THAT OF THIS GREAT FAMILY
PICTURE OF ME WHEN I'M ABOUT THE
FOURTH GRADE WITH MY GRANDMOTHER
AND MY BROTHER AT FORT ROSS, AND
WHO KNEW I WOULD BE SHOOTING OFF
A CANNON WITH THE RUSSIAN
AMBASSADOR THERE A FEW DECADES
LATER, BUT IT CREATED THAT KIND
OF INTEREST JUST IN THAT I THINK
WE HAVE IN THE PACKET THE
NUMBERS OF HOW MANY STUDENTS
UTILIZE THIS, ROUGHLY 17,020,
21, ALMOST 26,020 22, 5020 23.
BUT IT GIVES NO CHARACTERIZATION
OF WHO THEY ARE. AND I WONDERED
IF ANYBODY KNEW, BECAUSE IT
SEEMS TO MATTER TO ME IF WE'RE
SPENDING THIS MONEY AND IT'S
KIDS FROM DISADVANTAGED SCHOOLS,
THAT'S INCREDIBLE BECAUSE THEY
WOULDN'T GET THERE. IF IT'S KIDS
FROM BASIC AID SCHOOLS, THEN
WHAT THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST
JUST SAID PROBABLY APPLIES. THEY
PROBABLY HAVE EXTRA PROPERTY TAX
MONEY AND THEY SHOULD BE DOING
IT. AND I'M NOT PROPOSING AN
ABSOLUTE MEANS TESTING, BUT I'M
WONDERING IF WE HAVE A SENSE OF
WHO IS USING THIS. SO WE DO KNOW
THAT WE DO HAVE STATEWIDE USE. I
WOULD SAY THAT THROUGH THE
PROGRAMS THAT WE'VE OFFERED FOR
WEEKEND AND SUMMER
TRANSPORTATION THÀNH TRIPS, THAT
THE MAJORITY OF THOSE FAMILIES
ARE FROM UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES
AND TITLE ONE SCHOOLS, WE DO
HAVE SPECIFIC OUTREACH THAT WE
DO THROUGH DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION AND COUNTY OFFICES OF
EDUCATION TO TITLE ONE SCHOOLS.
SO WE DO KNOW THAT THAT THESE
PROGRAMS ARE IMPACTING FAMILIES
THAT EITHER HAVEN'T OTHERWISE
GONE TO PARKS, THAT DIDN'T KNOW
ABOUT PARKS, SO THAT WE KNOW
THAT WHERE WE ARE GETTING TO
FAMILIES THAT, YOU KNOW, FACED
BARRIERS TO ACCESSING PARKS. AND
IS THIS ANECDOTAL FROM WHAT YOU
JUST SAID? OR IS THIS ACTUALLY
CLEAR THROUGH SOME COLLECTION OF
INFORMATION? RIGHT. SO THE GRANT
PROGRAMS THAT WE'VE DONE THROUGH
OUR PARTNER PARKS CALIFORNIA,
THEY HAVE COLLECTED DATA AND
SURVEYS FROM GRANT RECIPIENTS
AND USERS OF THOSE PROGRAMS. SO
WE DO HAVE THOSE. DO YOU HAVE
THAT IN A SUMMARY THING OR DO
YOU HAVE. YEAH. WE COULD SEND
COULD YOU SEND THAT OVER TO THE
COMMITTEE. YES. GET A CHANCE TO
SEE THAT. AND YOU SEE ONE OF THE
INTERESTING THINGS IS, IS IN A
PRIOR JOB I HAD WHERE I ACTUALLY
WORKED WITH MISS MCGURK, I MOVED
UP AND DOWN THE STATE, AND I
NEVER CEASED TO BE AMAZED AT
KIDS IN SAN DIEGO THAT LIVE SIX
MILES FROM THE OCEAN, BUT HAD
NEVER BEEN TO THE OCEAN OR KIDS
THAT THE O'NEILL FAMILY DOES.
OUTDOOR EDUCATION. PEOPLE FROM
SAN JOSE HAD NEVER BEEN TO THE
OCEAN, AND I FOUND I WAS
SURPRISED IT WAS THIS
UNSOLICITED RECURRING THEME AS I
MOVED UP AND DOWN THE COAST. AND
SO I GET THIS. THIS IS SOMETHING
THAT THAT REALLY MAKES A
DIFFERENCE. I JUST WANT TO KNOW,
I, I DON'T WANT TO SINGLE OUT
SOME REALLY WEALTHY SCHOOL
DISTRICT, BUT I WANT TO KNOW
IT'S SERVING THE KIDS I JUST
MENTIONED. AND NOT JUST THAT. SO
I WILL LOOK FORWARD TO THAT
INFORMATION. YES AND THEN IN
ADDITION TO THE GRANT PROGRAM
SURVEYS, WE DO HAVE SURVEYS THAT
GO OUT TO INDIVIDUAL PASSHOLDER
FAMILIES. AND WE HAVEN'T HAD AS
MUCH UPTAKE ON COMPLETION OF
THOSE SURVEYS AS WE HAD HOPED
FOR. SO THROUGH OTHER
PARTNERSHIPS WITH PARK PARTNERS,
WE'RE ABLE TO OFFER INCENTIVES
FOR COMPLETION OF SURVEYS, AND
SO WE'RE HOPING TO HAVE MORE
DATA IN THE NEXT MONTH OR SO
FROM THAT AS WELL. THAT'D BE
GREAT. THAT ACTUALLY MIGHT BE
JUST IN TIME. YES. SO THANK YOU.
THANK YOU, ANY FOLLOW UP
QUESTIONS, SENATOR WILK?
ACTUALLY, JUST A COMMENT,
BECAUSE I WAS GOING TO SHARE THE
SAME THING. I WAS INVOLVED WITH
A, BOYS AND GIRLS CLUB IN
OXNARD, WHICH IS ON THE BEACH,
AND WE TOOK A BUNCH OF YOUNG
PEOPLE BORN AND RAISED IN OXNARD
, NEVER BEEN TO THE BEACH. AND
IT'S JUST LIKE, SO I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT TO GET THAT KIND OF
EXPOSURE. SO THAT'S ONE NUMBER
TWO, I WAS IN SONOMA COUNTY TWO
WEEKS AGO, AND I DROVE UP
BECAUSE OF WAYS FORT ROSS ROAD.
THAT'S LIKE AN ESCAPE ROUTE.
HAVE YOU BEEN ON THAT ROAD? NOT
EVEN A ROAD. YEAH, YEAH, I'M
REALLY AWARE OF THAT ROAD. HUESO
TOOK ME THAT WAY. FORTUNATELY, I
HAD RENTED A JEEP, SO IT WAS
OKAY, BUT IT WAS QUITE AN
ADVENTURE. GOT UP TO THE TOP,
TOOK SOME PHOTOS, BUT I DIDN'T
POST ANY BECAUSE IT DID NOT DO
JUSTICE TO THE BEAUTY OF THAT
AREA. BUT YEAH, CRAZY. NO, IT'S
WHEN I WAS AT RESOURCES, WE
NAMED A NEW PARKS DIRECTOR IN
THE MIDDLE OF A WEEK, AND SHE
REMINDED ME THAT SHE WAS
SCHEDULED TO GET MARRIED THAT
WEEKEND, AND IT WAS THE TIME
THAT THE RUSSIAN AMBASSADOR WAS
WAS VISITING FORT ROSS. SO MY
WEDDING PRESENT WAS A SEVEN HOUR
ROUND TRIP ON THAT ROAD TO LET
HER GO, GET MARRIED AND LET ME
BLOW OFF THE CANNON. AND THEN
I'D LIKE TO I'D LIKE TO SEE THAT
DATA TO WHEN IT COMES RIGHT. AND
I THINK THAT THAT THOSE WERE
REALLY OUR COMMENTS BECAUSE IN
GENERAL, THIS IS AN EXCELLENT
THING AND IT PROVIDES SOME HELP
TO PARKS, WHICH ALWAYS COULD USE
HELP. IT GETS PEOPLE THERE THAT
NEVER WOULD BE THERE OTHERWISE.
I THINK WE JUST WANT TO MAKE
SURE IT'S PROPERLY DIRECTED AND
IT'S AND THE RIGHT PEOPLE ARE
BENEFITING BY IT. ANY LAST
COMMENT THEN? THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. SORRY YOU HAD TO WAIT ALL
THE WAY THROUGH FOR SUCH A
LENGTHY DISCUSSION, THAT
COMPLETES THE FOUR ISSUES THAT
WE WERE CONSIDERING, BUT WE WANT
TO OFFER AN OPPORTUNITY FOR
PEOPLE TO MAKE PUBLIC COMMENT TO
THE COMMITTEE. SO LET ME ASK,
WHO IN THE ROOM IS DESIROUS OF
MAKING A PUBLIC COMMENT?
123456789 1011 1213 1415. THEN
LET'S DO OUR BEST TO LIMIT IT TO
A MINUTE, BUT WE WANT TO HEAR
FROM ALL 15 OF YOU. SO IF YOU
WOULD MOVE TO THIS MICROPHONE
OAN AND, AND START WITH YOUR
NAME AND ANY ORGANIZATION AND,
AND GIVE US THE BENEFIT OF WHAT
YOUR THOUGHTS ARE ON, ON THESE
ITEMS. WELCOME TO THE COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING. I'M
LUCY SALCIDO CARTER, I'M
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF THE
ALAMEDA COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION, WE, AMONG OTHER
THINGS, SUPPORT OUR SCHOOLS
COUNTYWIDE AND SERVING STUDENTS
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS AT ANY
POINT IN TIME. WE HAVE ROUGHLY
4000 STUDENTS EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS IN OUR COUNTY. WE
ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE
$1.5 MILLION PROPOSED ALLOCATION
FOR THE TAX, WE VALUE THE HEAT
TAX BECAUSE THEIR EXPERTS ARE
AVAILABLE TO ANSWER QUESTIONS IN
REAL TIME SO THAT SCHOOLS CAN
HELP STUDENTS AND FAMILIES IN
REAL TIME. THEY PROVIDE VITAL
INFORMATION ON HOW TO IDENTIFY
STUDENTS EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS, REFER THEM TO
SERVICES, AND PROVIDE MODEL
PROGRAMING. OUR REGIONAL HEAT
TAC HAS HELPED US CREATE A LOCAL
NETWORK OF SUPPORT FOR OUR
STUDENTS. WE ALSO TURN TO THE
TAC TEAM FOR CONSULTATION ON
MCKINNEY-VENTO PROVISIONS TO
ENSURE THAT THE RIGHTS OF OUR
STUDENTS ARE MET. FOR THESE
REASONS, WE ASK THAT YOU SUPPORT
THE PROPOSED $1.5 MILLION FOR
THE HEAT TAX. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. APPRECIATE YOUR
COMMENTS. WELCOME. THANK YOU,
HELLO. I'M PIXIE POPPLEWELL, I
AM THE CALIFORNIA HOMELESS YOUTH
PROJECT DIRECTOR, AND I'LL BE
SPEAKING ON THE TAC CENTERS
THROUGH DATA AND STUDENT
EXPERIENCE, THERE ARE 1800
LIAISONS DESIGNATED TO SERVE THE
248,000 HOMELESS STUDENTS ACROSS
THE STATE. THAT IS AN AVERAGE OF
140 STUDENTS PER LIAISON WITH
HEAVIER CASELOADS IN REGIONS
LIKE SAN LUIS OBISPO, WITH 243
AND ORANGE WITH 490 STUDENTS PER
LIAISON. IN COMPARISON, THE
RECOMMENDED CASELOAD FOR SOCIAL
WORKERS IS 15 TO 24. FOR 97% OF
THESE LIAISONS, SUPPORTING
HOMELESS STUDENTS IS ADDITIONAL
TO BEING A PRINCIPAL OR
SUPERINTENDENT. THE CONSEQUENCES
ARE FELT BY STUDENTS. ONE
STUDENT SPOKE ON IMPACT. IT'S
REALLY HARD TO MANAGE GOING TO
SCHOOL IN GENERAL AND THEN
DEALING WITH BEING HOMELESS AT
THE SAME TIME. I DIDN'T HAVE ANY
MOTIVATION TO GO TO SCHOOL
ANYMORE. IT WAS JUST HARD. I WAS
COUCH SURFING OR HAD TO STAY
WITH A FAMILY MEMBER THAT LIVED
IN A DIFFERENT CITY. ANOTHER
STUDENT SPOKE ON AWARENESS. IT'S
SO DIFFICULT TO FIND THOSE
RESOURCES. I HAD TO TALK TO MY
COUNSELOR AND TELL HER WHAT WAS
GOING ON AT HOME FOR HER TO TELL
ME ABOUT A PROGRAM. THERE WAS NO
POSTER. IT'S NOT ADVERTISED OUT
THERE. LIKE, WHAT IF I DIDN'T
ASK? I HOPE THAT THIS THESE
STATEMENTS PROVIDE A FOUNDATION
FOR THE SPEAKERS THAT FOLLOW.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
APPRECIATE YOUR COMMENTS.
WELCOME TO THE COMMITTEE. HI,
CHAIR AND MEMBERS. GUTIERREZ
FROM THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF FOOD BANKS, AND ON BEHALF OF
GRACE AND CHILD POVERTY, THANK
YOU, CHAIR LAIRD, FOR LIFTING UP
SCHOOL MEALS FOR ALL AND ALL IT
DOES, ESPECIALLY REMOVING STIGMA
, AS WE HEARD AMONG CALIFORNIA'S
FAMILIES WHO ARE EXPERIENCING
FOOD INSECURITY, NEARLY HALF
INCOMES ARE TOO HIGH TO MEET THE
FEDERAL ELIGIBILITY REQUIREMENTS
FOR FREE AND REDUCED PRICE
MEALS. SO NOW MORE THAN EVER,
YOU KNOW, SCHOOL MEALS FOR ALL
IS THE MOST IMPORTANT CHANGE TO
EDUCATION POLICY IN DECADES,
ENSURING THAT ALL STUDENTS HAVE
ACCESS TO NUTRITIOUS MEALS AT
SCHOOL TO SUPPORT THEIR LEARNING
AND HEALTH. AS MENTIONED EARLIER
, THERE'S NO SILVER BULLET FOR,
YOU KNOW, FOR THERE'S ALL KINDS
OF DIFFERENT WAYS TO MAXIMIZE.
AND ONE I WANT TO LIFT UP IS
SUMMER ET, THE NEW FEDERAL
PROGRAM THAT'S GOING TO BE AN
AVENUE TO INCENTIVIZE FAMILIES
TO COME TO FILL OUT A MEAL
APPLICATION OR FORM. SO THAT'S
GOING TO BE A GREAT PATHWAY TO
DO THAT. WE'RE GRATEFUL TO
CALIFORNIA LEADING THE WAY AND
THE NATION FOR SCHOOL MEALS FOR
ALL. AND WE ASK FOR SUPPORT FOR
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED PROPOSAL
TO FULLY FUND SCHOOL MEALS FOR
ALL. THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. APPRECIATE YOUR COMMENTS.
WELCOME TO THE COMMITTEE. THANK
YOU, GOOD MORNING, CHAIR MEMBERS
CAPRI WALKER, ON BEHALF OF NO
KID HUNGRY AND ALTAMED, WE URGE
THE LEGISLATURE TO MAINTAIN
CALIFORNIA'S COMMITMENT TO
EXPANDING ACCESS TO NUTRITIOUS
SCHOOL MEALS AND SUMMER MEALS,
AND CONTINUE INVESTING IN THE
WELL-BEING OF STUDENTS. AS WE
HAVE SEEN FIRSTHAND HOW
IMPORTANT ADDITIONAL STATE FUNDS
ARE TO SCHOOL BASED ANTI-HUNGER
PROGRAMS AND UNDERSTAND THAT
FOOD INSECURITY IS A PUBLIC
HEALTH ISSUE. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. GOOD MORNING,
CHAIR AND MEMBERS, ALICIA ROSEN
FROM THE PLACER COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION. JUST UP THE 80. LAST
SCHOOL YEAR. OUR SCHOOL
DISTRICTS IDENTIFIED OVER 2000
STUDENTS EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS IN OUR COUNTY,
WHICH IS KIND OF SURPRISING IF
YOU THINK ABOUT THE DEMOGRAPHICS
OF PLACER COUNTY. THESE STUDENTS
AND THEIR FAMILIES, FAMILIES ARE
LIVING IN TENUOUS SHARED HOUSING
SITUATIONS. OTHERWISE KNOWN AS
DOUBLED UP OR SLEEPING IN THEIR
CARS OR STAYING IN SHELTERS, OR
PAYING EXORBITANT DAILY RATES
FOR MOTEL ROOMS BECAUSE THEY
DON'T HAVE THE CREDIT OR A
SECURITY DEPOSIT TO AFFORD AN
APARTMENT. MOST PLACER COUNTY
SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND MY COUNTY
OFFICE OF EDUCATION RECEIVE VERY
LITTLE FUNDING TO SUPPORT THE
MULTIPLE COMPLEX NEEDS OF THESE
STUDENTS AND THEIR FAMILIES. TO
THAT END, WE GREATLY RELY ON THE
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE,
CONSULTATION AND COACHING WE
RECEIVE FROM THE HEAT TAX. THEIR
TEAM REPORT PROVIDES RESPONSIVE,
INFORMED AND ROBUST GUIDANCE ON
COMPLEX HOMELESS SITUATIONS,
HELPING ME AND MY COLLEAGUES TO
PROVIDE THE MOST TRAUMA
INFORMED, LEGALLY SOUND AND
SENSIBLE SUPPORT TO THESE
STUDENTS AND THEIR FAMILIES. IF
I DIDN'T HAVE HEAT AT THE READY
WITH THIS CRITICAL SUPPORT, MY
ABILITY TO GUIDE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS AND DIRECTLY SUPPORT
UNHOUSED STUDENTS WOULD BE
NEARLY IMPOSSIBLE. PLEASE
CONTINUE TO FUND HEAT TAX. THANK
YOU, THANK YOU. APPRECIATE YOUR
COMMENTS. WELCOME. HI. GOOD
MORNING, CHAIR AND MEMBERS, LIZ
FENTON FOR THE OFFICE OF KAT
TAYLOR AND THE SCHOOL MEALS FOR
ALL COALITION. WE REPRESENT OVER
150 GROUPS IN SUPPORT OF THE
GOVERNOR'S JANUARY PROPOSAL TO
FULLY FUND THE SCHOOL MEALS FOR
ALL PROGRAM. THANK YOU, SENATOR
LAIRD. SENATOR WILK, FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP IN PASSING THE SCHOOL
MEALS FOR ALL PROGRAM. FOR MANY
OF OUR STUDENTS, THIS IS THE
ONLY MEAL THAT THEY WILL GET ALL
DAY. WE WANT TO RECOGNIZE THE
DIFFICULT CHOICES YOU MUST MAKE
IN THE FACE OF A MASSIVE BUDGET
SHORTFALL. AND WE'RE WORKING
VERY CLOSELY WITH THE DEPARTMENT
AND BUDGET STAFF TO MAXIMIZE
FEDERAL REIMBURSEMENTS AND
ENCOURAGE FAMILIES TO
PARTICIPATE IN THE PROGRAM.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. GOOD MORNING. MY NAME
IS KENISHA LOPEZ, AND CHAIR AND
MEMBERS. MY NAME IS KANITRA
LOPEZ AND I LIVE IN ROSEVILLE,
CALIFORNIA AND PLACER COUNTY.
ACTUALLY, I'M AN EDUCATOR AND
I'VE SERVED AS A SCHOOL
ADMINISTRATOR, AND I HAVE THREE
CHILDREN THAT RANGE FROM
PRESCHOOL TO MIDDLE SCHOOL AGE.
I'M HERE TODAY ON BEHALF OF
WOMEN'S FOUNDATION CALIFORNIA
AND IN PARTNERSHIP WITH THE
COALITION FOR SCHOOL MEALS FOR
ALL AND I'M HERE TO REALLY
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF FULLY
FUNDING, SCHOOL MEALS FOR ALL
FOR MANY OF THE STUDENTS IN MY
CHILDREN'S SCHOOL, ARE THE
DEMOGRAPHICS OF OUR NEIGHBORHOOD
IS CHANGING. THERE'S LOTS OF
STUDENTS WHO HAVE COME FROM
DIFFERENT PLACES AND, PROVIDING
MEALS AND ALLOWING ALL STUDENTS
TO ENGAGE IN A MEAL TOGETHER HAS
BEEN, VERY SUPPORTIVE IN THE
SCHOOL CULTURE AND ENVIRONMENT
THAT MY STUDENTS HAVE BEEN A
PART OF. ALSO FUNDING THIS
PROPOSAL ESSENTIALLY IS VERY
IMPORTANT FOR ADVANCING RACIAL
EQUITY AND JUSTICE AND ENSURING
BLACK, INDIGENOUS AND LATINX
STUDENTS RECEIVE, ACCESS AND A
NUTRITION TO BE ABLE TO BE ABLE
TO LEARN AND BE ABLE TO
DEMONSTRATE THEIR KNOWLEDGE IN
SCHOOL AND FURTHER. SO THANK YOU
FOR SUPPORT AND LISTENING AND
FOR CONSIDERATION AND SUPPORT OF
THIS. AND I HOPE THAT WE FIND
SOME WAY. I KNOW THERE'S NO
MAGIC BULLET, BUT SOME WAY TO
CONTINUE THIS, BECAUSE IT'S BEEN
REALLY HELPFUL. ALL ALL THE
COSTS ARE ADDING UP AS INFLATION
GOES UP. AND SO THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT EVEN THOSE THAT
DON'T QUALIFY, AND IT FLUCTUATES
CAN BE ABLE TO COUNT ON FOR
THEIR STUDENTS. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. WELCOME. GOOD
MORNING. SARAH BRENNAN WITH
WHITMAN GROUP HERE REPRESENTING
NEXT GEN CALIFORNIA. WE
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST THE
COMMITTEE SUPPORT THE GOVERNOR'S
JANUARY BUDGET PROPOSAL TO FULLY
FUND CALIFORNIA'S SCHOOL MEALS
FOR ALL PROGRAM. ACCORDING TO
THE CALIFORNIA BUDGET AND POLICY
CENTER, 44% OF FAMILIES FACING
FOOD INSECURITY IN CALIFORNIA
WOULD NOT QUALIFY FOR FREE AND
REDUCED PRICED SCHOOL MEALS
BECAUSE OF FEDERAL PROGRAMS.
INCOME REQUIREMENTS ARE TOO LOW
FOR STATES WHERE IT'S MORE
EXPENSIVE, LIKE CALIFORNIA, FOR
SCHOOL MEALS FOR ALL BRIDGES
THAT GAP THE PROGRAM IS WORKING
AND SERVES AS A MODEL FOR OTHER
STATES ON HOW TO INVEST IN
SCHOOL MEALS, ON HOW INVESTING
IN SCHOOL MEALS REDUCES STIGMA
AND CHILD HUNGER. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. WELCOME.
GOOD MORNING, CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
ABBY HALPRIN WITH THE CENTER FOR
ECOLITERACY IN SUPPORT OF SCHOOL
MEALS FOR ALL AND MAINTAINING
FULL FUNDING FOR SCHOOL MEALS,
AS PROPOSED IN THE GOVERNOR'S
JANUARY BUDGET. WE WORK WITH A
NETWORK OF 120 SCHOOL DISTRICTS
ACROSS CALIFORNIA, AND THEY HAVE
TOLD US LOUD AND CLEAR SCHOOL
MEALS FOR ALL IS WORKING. THANK
YOU, SENATOR LAIRD, FOR YOUR
EXCELLENT QUESTIONS AND
LEADERSHIP ON THIS ISSUE. I WAS
GOING TO TALK ABOUT ALL THE
POSITIVE IMPACTS THAT THIS
PROGRAM IS HAPPENING FROM THE
SINGLE MOTHER IN SAN LUIS
COASTAL, WHO NO LONGER HAS TO
WORRY ABOUT HER CHILD'S NEXT
MEAL. TO THE STUDENTS IN TUSTIN
UNIFIED, WHO REPORT THAT THEY
DON'T AREN'T CONCERNED WITH
SOCIOECONOMIC STATUS. BUT
INSTEAD, I WANT TO RESPOND
DIRECTLY TO YOUR QUESTIONS
AROUND MAXIMIZING THE FEDERAL
REIMBURSEMENT. YOU DID ALREADY A
GOOD JOB OF NAMING THE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS WHERE THEY'RE IN THE
DISTRICTS OF COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
SO YOU'VE ALREADY SCORED ONE.
YEAH. THANK YOU, SENATOR, AS CDE
SPOKE ABOUT, THERE ARE SOLUTIONS
THAT THEY'RE PREPARED TO ROLL
OUT. LIKE PROBABLY MATCHING,
LOCAL MATCHING AND MORE FREQUENT
MATCHING THAT CAN HELP US BETTER
IDENTIFY THE STUDENTS THAT ARE
ALREADY ELIGIBLE FOR OUR PUBLIC
BENEFIT PROGRAMS, BUT AREN'T
BEING CAPTURED IN SCHOOL MEALS
OR IN THE CURRENT FREE OR
REDUCED PRICE MEAL COUNTS. AT
THE SAME TIME, THERE'S AN
OPPORTUNITY TO SUPPORT SCHOOLS
IN BETTER COMMUNICATION TO
FAMILIES WITH A COMMUNICATIONS
TOOLKIT IN MULTIPLE LANGUAGES
THAT REALLY ADDRESSES WHAT KIM
SPOKE ABOUT, ABOUT THE BROADER
BENEFITS OF THE MEAL. SO WE'RE
COMMITTED TO WORKING WITH YOU
AND EVERYONE HERE ON IDENTIFYING
THOSE SOLUTIONS AND CONTINUING
TO PROTECT AND PRESERVE THIS
IMPORTANT PROGRAM WITHOUT
PUTTING MORE OF A BURDEN BACK ON
THE SCHOOL DISTRICTS. THANK YOU
SO MUCH. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
WELCOME, WELCOME. GOOD MORNING.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME TODAY.
MY NAME IS SUSIE TERRY AND I'M
THE COORDINATOR FOR HOMELESS
EDUCATION SERVICES AT THE SAN
DIEGO COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION. I SUPPORT ALL THE LÀ,
SCHOOL DISTRICT AND CHARTER
SCHOOL LIAISONS IN SAN DIEGO
COUNTY WITH PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT AND TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE IN SUPPORT OF THE
OVER 20,000 STUDENTS IDENTIFIED
AS EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS IN
SAN DIEGO COUNTY. I ALSO SERVE
AS ONE OF THE HOMELESS EDUCATION
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE CENTER, OR
HE TECH LEADS, HELPING
COORDINATE AND FACILITATE THE
STATEWIDE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
AND SUPPORT OF COUNTY OFFICE AND
LEA LIAISONS. I'M IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE 1.5 MILLION
ALLOCATION FOR THE HOMELESS
EDUCATION TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
CENTER. PRIOR TO AMERICAN RESCUE
PLAN FUNDS, AND ONCE THEY
EXPIRE, CALIFORNIA'S FINANCIAL
SUPPORT OF HOMELESS EDUCATION
PROGRAMS HAS BEEN EXCLUSIVE TO
THE FEDERAL MCKINNEY-VENTO FUNDS
OR EDUCATION FOR HOMELESS
CHILDREN AND YOUTH FUNDS THAT
ARE ALLOCATED TO STATES. THOSE
FUNDS ARE GRANTED OUT TO LEAS IN
SUB GRANTS TO SUPPORT HOMELESS
STUDENTS. WHILE CALIFORNIA IS
HOME TO THE LARGEST NUMBER OF
STUDENTS EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS THAN ANY OTHER
STATE, A MERE 8% OF LOCAL
EDUCATION AGENCIES RECEIVE ANY
OF THOSE FUNDS, 8% DUE TO THE
LACK OF DEDICATED FUNDING, THE
LIAISON POSITION IS OFTEN FILLED
BY THOSE WEARING OTHER HATS.
PRINCIPALS. ADMINISTRATORS. THE
SPECIAL EDUCATION DIRECTOR, AND
IN SOME CASES THE SUPERINTENDENT
ARE ALSO ACTING AS THE HOMELESS
LIAISON. THIS DOESN'T ALLOW FOR
THE INTENSIVE SUPPORT AND
SERVICES THAT STUDENTS NEED AND
DESERVE. IN WITH THEIR UNIQUE
AND OFTENTIMES COMPLICATED NEEDS
. IT DOES NOT ALLOW FOR LOCAL OR
COUNTY LIAISONS TO ALWAYS HAVE
THE TIME TO HAVE THE SUBJECT
MATTER EXPERTISE NECESSARY TO
KNOW HOW TO PROPERLY IMPLEMENT
ALL OF THE STATUTES RELATED TO
HOMELESS EDUCATION IN ALL
SITUATIONS. A RECENT SURVEY BY
UC SAN FRANCISCO SHOWED THAT 50%
OF LOCAL LIAISONS HAVE FIVE
HOURS OR LESS PER WEEK TO SPEND
ON THEIR HOMELESS EDUCATION
DUTIES. THE HEAT ACTS PROVIDE
CRITICAL SUPPORT TO COUNTY
OFFICE OF ED AND SCHOOL
DISTRICTS TO ENSURE EDUCATIONAL
ACCESS AND SUCCESS OF CHILDREN
AND YOUTH EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS. THE HEAT TAX HAVE
BEEN ABLE TO BRING PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT AND TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE MORE EASILY AND
BROADLY TO C  IN SUPPORT OF
THEIR LEAS TO QUICKLY ANSWER
QUESTIONS, GIVE GUIDANCE,
PROVIDE TRAINING TOOLKITS AND
SAMPLES FOR LEAS STRAINED BY
TIME AND OTHER RESPONSIBILITIES.
THIS HELPS ENSURE THAT STUDENTS
ARE RECEIVING THE SUPPORTS AND
ENTITLEMENTS THAT THEY DESERVE.
THIS IS ESPECIALLY IMPORTANT
CONSIDERING THAT RESEARCH HAS
SHOWN THAT LACK OF A HIGH SCHOOL
DIPLOMA OR GED IS THE SINGLE
GREATEST RISK FACTOR FOR FUTURE
HOMELESSNESS. EDUCATION PLAYS A
CRITICAL ROLE IN HOMELESS
RESPONSE. THESE FUNDS WOULD
WOULD REPRESENT THE FIRST STATE
INVESTMENT IN STUDENTS
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS, AND
WOULD COME AT A CRITICAL TIME AS
OTHER FUNDING SOURCES ARE
EXPIRING. FOR THESE REASONS, I'M
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE 1.5
MILLION ALLOCATION FOR HOMELESS
EDUCATION TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
CENTERS IN THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSED BUDGET. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. WELCOME.
GOOD MORNING. MY NAME IS DOCTOR
JENNIFER KOTTKE, AND I AM THE
HOMELESS EDUCATION PROJECT
DIRECTOR, Tê WITH THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION. I WANT TO THANK YOU
FOR HEARING THIS IMPORTANT
MATTER TODAY. AND MY ROLE AS THE
COUNTY OFFICE HOMELESS LIAISON
FOR LACOE. I SERVE AND SUPPORT
THE 80 SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND 370
PLUS CHARTER SCHOOLS WITHIN L.A.
COUNTY. WE HAVE A COUNT OF OVER
58,000 IDENTIFIED MCKINNEY-VENTO
STUDENTS IN L.A. COUNTY, AND
MANY MORE THAT HAVE NOT BEEN
IDENTIFIED AND SHOULD BE AND I
HAVE THE HONOR OF ALSO HAVE
BEING SELECTED AS ONE OF THE
THREE HOMELESS EDUCATION
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE CENTER
LEADS. AND I'VE HAD THE
PRIVILEGE TO WORK ALONGSIDE
CONTRA COSTA COUNTY AND SAN
DIEGO COUNTY THESE PAST TWO AND
A HALF YEARS. TODAY, I WANT TO
EXPRESS MY STRONG SUPPORT FOR
THE $1.5 MILLION ALLOCATED FOR
THE HEAT TAX. CURRENTLY,
CALIFORNIA RELIES SOLELY ON
FEDERAL FUNDS TO SUPPORT THE
STUDENT POPULATION, SO IN
ALLOWING THE $1.5 MILLION TO
REMAIN IN THE BUDGET TO SUPPORT
THE HEAT TAX, CALIFORNIA WILL BE
TAKING PIVOTAL STEPS TOWARDS
INTENTIONALLY INVESTING IN
SUPPORTING THE WORK FOR ENSURING
OUR STUDENTS EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS ARE NOT JUST
SURVIVING, BUT THEY'RE THRIVING.
THIS FUNDING WILL ALLOW US TO
CONTINUE THE WORK THAT HAS DRAWN
THE 58 COUNTY OFFICES OF
EDUCATION HOMELESS LIAISONS
TOGETHER TO SUPPORT AND THEN
SUPPORT AND NETWORK THEM AROUND
THE USE OF EDUCATION TO BE A
LIFE CHANGING AVENUE AND TO
ENSURE IT IS THE PREVENTATIVE
TOOL IT SHOULD BE TO AVOID YOUNG
PEOPLE FROM ENTERING INTO OUR
HUD HOMELESS SYSTEMS. HETAC
FUNDING HAS AND WILL HELP TO
CONTINUE TO BUILD CAPACITY IN
OUR COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION,
WHICH TRICKLES DOWN TO OUR
DISTRICTS AND OUR CHARTERS AND
ULTIMATELY EMPOWERS FAMILIES AND
STUDENTS. THIS FUNDING WILL
ALLOW US TO DO THE WORK WE
SHOULD BE DOING, WITH A DEEP
HOPE THAT THE OUTCOMES WILL DRAW
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA TO WANT
TO CONTINUE TO INVEST IN THIS
LIFE CHANGING WORK, PARTICULARLY
WITH ADDITIONAL FUNDING NEEDED
TO PROPERLY SUPPORT THIS
POPULATION. AND FOR THIS REASON,
I STRONGLY SUPPORT THE $1.5
MILLION ALLOCATED FOR THE HEAT
TAC. THANK YOU AGAIN FOR YOUR
TIME. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
WELCOME TO THE COMMITTEE. THANK
YOU. GOOD MORNING. SO YOU'VE NOW
MET TWO OF THE HEAT TAX AND I'M
THE THIRD ONE. I'M ALEJANDRA
CHAMBERLAIN. I AM WITH THE
CONTRA COSTA COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION. I'VE HAD THE PLEASURE
TO WORK WITH SUSIE AND JENNIFER
LÀ AND SAN DIEGO. THESE LAST TWO
YEARS HAVE BEEN AMAZING AS
EVERYTHING THEY'VE SAID, THE
HEAT TAX HAVE REALLY GIVEN AN
ARM TO CDE TO SUPPORT THE CEOS
AND THE LEAS. WHAT I HOPE TO
ACCOMPLISH BY SHARING MY
THOUGHTS AND PERSPECTIVE IS TO
PULL ON THE HEARTS OF YOU ALL
SITTING UP THERE. WHEN WE ARE
THINKING ABOUT OUR LEAS, WE'RE
PARTICULARLY ONLY THINKING ABOUT
OUR CHILDREN AND YOUTH WHO ARE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS. AND
WHEN I HEARD YOUR COMMENTS IN
REGARDS TO WHAT DO THE HEAT TAX
DO TO REALLY SUPPORT THE LEAS IN
REGARDS TO TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
AND PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT?
AND THAT IS REALLY THINKING
ABOUT SOLUTIONS, HOW WE CAN
SUPPORT OUR CHILDREN AND YOUTH.
AND YOU MIGHT BE THINKING LIKE,
WELL, WHAT DOES THAT REALLY
MEAN? SO I HAVE THE PLEASURE OF
MEETING MONTHLY WITH OUR SCHOOL
DISTRICTS AND NOT TOO LONG AGO,
I WANT TO SAY TWO WEEKS AGO WE
HAD SAN FRANCISCO UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT PRESENT THEIR STATE
OVER PROGRAM, WHICH WAS ALREADY
MENTIONED WHERE THEY TOOK THEIR
GYM AND THEY CREATED IT INTO A
SHELTER AFTER SCHOOL HOURS. THAT
THAT TOOK INCREDIBLE WORK,
COLLABORATION, COORDINATION
THÀNH INNOVATION, NOT ONLY FROM
THE LIAISON ON THE DISTRICT, THE
CITY, THE COUNTY, AND TO REALLY
GET THE COMMUNITY TO UNDERSTAND
THAT EVERY FAMILY, EVERY CHILD,
EVERY YOUTH SHOULD HAVE
SOMEWHERE TO STAY. SO WE BROUGHT
THEM TO OUR MONTHLY MEETING AND
I HOPEFULLY INSPIRED SOME OF OUR
DISTRICTS TO DO THE SAME. I'M WE
HAVE A CRUCIAL HOMELESS CRISIS
IN OUR COUNTY, CONTRA COSTA, AND
ANTIOCH IS PARTICULARLY ONE OF
THE CITIES WHO CONTINUES TO SAY
TO ME, ALEJANDRA, WHAT AM I
SUPPOSED TO DO WHEN I HAVE A 17
YEAR OLD COMING TO MY DOOR ON A
FRIDAY AT 3:00 SAYING I HAVE
NOWHERE TO GO? AS A COMMUNITY,
WE HAVE TO DO MORE FOR OUR
CHILDREN AND YOUTH BECAUSE THEY
DON'T BECOME HOMELESS WHEN THEY
TURN 18, SO THAT THEY COULD GET
HUD SERVICES RIGHT. THEY BECOME
HOMELESS BEFORE THAT. BUT OUR
COMMUNITY DOESN'T SEE IT BECAUSE
THEY DON'T SEE THEY DON'T, FIT
THE HUD DEFINITION. THÀNH. BUT
WHO SEES IT EVERY DAY IN AND OUT
IS OUR LIAISONS, NOT ONLY AT THE
DISTRICT LEVEL, BUT AT THE KHÓ
LEVEL. AND SO THIS FUNDING GIVES
OUR LIAISONS AN OPPORTUNITY TO
COLLABORATE, COLLABORATE AND
COORDINATE MORE EFFECTIVELY ON
BEHALF OF EVERY CHILD AND YOUTH
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS. SO
WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT YOUR
CONSTITUENTS, THINK ABOUT ALL OF
THOSE CHILDREN AND YOUTH WHO ARE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. I LET YOU GO WAY
OVER, BUT YOU HAD A MESSAGE THAT
I DIDN'T REALLY WANT TO
INTERRUPT. MY LEGS WERE GETTING
A LITTLE SHAKY, SO PARDON MY
SITTING DOWN. GOOD MORNING. MY
NAME IS AMY MOLINA. MOLINA
JONES, AND I'M THE DIRECTOR OF
PREVENTION, SUPPORT AND SERVICES
WITH THE YUBA COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION. I'VE BEEN WITH THE C
FOR OVER 30 YEARS, AND I AM,
PROUDLY THE HOMELESS LIAISON FOR
THE COUNTY, WE HAVE RECEIVED
SUPPORT FROM THE HIGH-TECH THAT
HAS CHANGED THE WAY WE DO
BUSINESS IN THE COUNTY OF YUBA.
WITH THE GUIDANCE FROM MY
COLLEAGUES FROM KTEC, OUR
DEPARTMENT HAS ENGAGED HOMELESS
YOUTH MORE INTENSELY THAN WE
HAVE EVER BEFORE. OUR HIGH-TECH
CONNECTED US WITH A PROFESSOR
FROM UC BERKELEY, WHERE WE
LEARNED HOW TO CONDUCT YOUTH
FORUMS. WE PARTNERED WITH OUR BY
COUNTY SALVATION ARMY AND
CONDUCTED A Y PLAN, WHICH WAS
ESSENTIALLY, WE CAPTURED THE
THOUGHTS OF OUR YOUTH REGARDING
THEIR LACK OF HOUSING. OUR FIRST
FORUM TOOK PLACE RIGHT BEFORE
THE HOLIDAYS, AND OUR YOUTH
VOICED CONCERNS ABOUT FOOD
INSECURITIES. AND IN RESPONSE,
OUR STAFF DID A DEEPER DIVE WITH
OUR LOCAL FOOD BANK. NOT ONLY
DID WE PROVIDE THE LOCATION OF
WHERE THEY COULD PICK UP FOOD
BOXES, BUT WE ARRANGED
TRANSPORTATION FOR OUR FAMILIES
TO GET THOSE BOXES. SIMILARLY TO
THE PROJECT YOU MENTIONED
EARLIER, SENATOR LAIRD IN
MONTEREY COUNTY, IT TAKES A LOT
OF MAN HOURS AND I'M SURE YOU
MET PERSON HOURS. I I DID
ABSOLUTELY. JUST CHECKING. IT
TAKES A LOT OF PEOPLE, AND
RELATIONSHIP BUILDING AND TRUST
THROUGH THE CONSULTATION WITH
OUR COLLEAGUES FROM SEATAC. WE
HAVE ALSO I'VE ALSO BECOME THE
SQUEAKY WHEEL FOR OUR CONTINUUM
OF CARE. MY REPRESENTATION AT
MONTHLY MEETINGS HAS BROUGHT
ATTENTION TO THE CAC'S TO
ADDRESS THEM. SERVING OUR YOUTH
WITH LOCAL FUNDING. AS A RESULT,
OUR DEPARTMENT WILL RECEIVE
LOCAL FUNDS TO EXPAND SERVICES
THROUGH THE HOMELESS HOUSING
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM, WHICH IN
TURN WILL PROVIDE FUNDING FOR A
FULL TIME STAFF DEDICATED TO
SERVING OUR HOMELESS YOUTH. BUT
IT'S THE PARTNERSHIP COULD BEGIN
TO WRAP UP. OKAY. THE
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE TAC HAS
GREATLY BEEN INSTRUMENTAL IN
OPENING OUR THOSE DOORS FOR THE
FUNDING. AND WITH THAT, I JUST
HOPE THAT WE CAN CONTINUE TO
FUND THE TAC. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. WELCOME TO THE
COMMITTEE. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING, DENISE CLARK WITH
CONTRA COSTA COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION, I'VE SORT OF
SUPPORTED THE EDUCATION FOR
HOMELESS CHILDREN AND YOUTH
PROGRAM IN CONTRA COSTA FOR OVER
TEN YEARS AND WANT TO EXPRESS MY
STRONG SUPPORT FOR THE
ALLOCATION OF 1.5 MILLION
TOWARDS THE TAC IN CALIFORNIA,
THESE CENTERS PLAY A CRUCIAL
ROLE IN PROVIDING ESSENTIAL
SUPPORT AND RESOURCES TO
HOMELESS EDUCATION LIAISON
ACROSS ALL 58 STATES COUNTIES IN
OUR STATE. ADDITIONALLY, THEY
SERVE AS A VITAL STATEWIDE
RESOURCE HUB, THE FIRST
STATEWIDE RESOURCE HUB. IN
ADDITION TO CGRTS WEBSITE,
EQUIPPING ALL EDUCATORS WITH THE
TOOLS AND KNOWLEDGE NECESSARY TO
EFFECTIVELY IDENTIFY AND SUPPORT
STUDENTS EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS. WHILE EACH
DISTRICT OR LÀ HAS A HOMELESS
EDUCATION LIAISON, AS WAS
MENTIONED EARLIER, IT COULD BE
ANYBODY FROM A PRINCIPAL, A
SUPERINTENDENT, A SCHOOL
COUNSELOR. THERE'S HIGH TURNOVER
IN THOSE POSITIONS. THIS,
HOMELESS EDUCATION LIAISONS FACE
SIGNIFICANT CHALLENGES IN
PROVIDING ADEQUATE SUPPORT
WITHOUT SUFFICIENT RESOURCES AND
GUIDANCE, THE TAC SERVE AS
INVALUABLE PARTNERS IN THIS
ENDEAVOR, OFFERING SPECIALIZED
TRAINING, TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE,
AND ACCESS TO BEST PRACTICES. BY
FOSTERING COLLABORATION, THÀNH
AND OFFERING STATEWIDE
RESOURCES, HE TAX ENHANCE OUR
ABILITY TO ADDRESS STUDENT
HOMELESSNESS COMPREHENSIVELY
THROUGH STRATEGIES LIKE
KNOWLEDGE SHARING AND CAPACITY
BUILDING. THEY EMPOWER EDUCATORS
TO RECOGNIZE EARLY SIGNS OF
HOMELESSNESS, INTERVENE
PROMPTLY, AND CONNECT STUDENTS
AND FAMILIES WITH VITAL
SERVICES. I URGE YOU TO
PRIORITIZE AND APPROVE THE 1.5
MILLION ALLOCATION FOR THE
HOMELESS EDUCATIONAL, TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE CENTER IN THE
UPCOMING BUDGET, AND YOUR
SUPPORT WILL ENSURE THE
CONTINUATION OF THIS CRITICAL
ASSISTANCE PROVIDED BY THE HEAT
TAX. THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. WELCOME. GOOD MORNING.
PAGE CLARK WITH THE NATIONAL
CENTER FOR YOUTH LAW. THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE
COMMENTS THIS MORNING AS THE
STATE GRAPPLES WITH AN
INCREASINGLY CHALLENGING BUDGET
PICTURE, WE ASK THE LEGISLATURE
TO MAINTAIN CRITICAL SUPPORTS
AND SERVICES TO SUPPORT SOME OF
OUR MOST UNDERSERVED STUDENTS.
THOSE EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS.
DATA SHOWS THAT STUDENTS
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS ARE
GRADUATING HIGH SCHOOL AT RATES
ABOUT 15 PERCENTAGE POINTS BELOW
THEIR PEERS, AND THE TWO LEADING
RISK FACTORS FOR ADULT
HOMELESSNESS ARE NOT HAVING A
HIGH SCHOOL DIPLOMA AND
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS AS A
YOUNG PERSON. STUDENTS
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS ARE
ALSO MORE LIKELY TO BE IMPACTED
BY CHRONIC ABSENTEEISM FROM
SCHOOL MOBILITY AND EXCLUSIONARY
DISCIPLINE POLICIES. WITH
AMERICAN RESCUE PLAN FUNDING
EXPIRING LATER THIS YEAR, MUCH
OF THE WORK MY COLLEAGUES DO TO
STRENGTHEN OUR SYSTEM'S CAPACITY
TO SERVE OUR STUDENTS WILL END,
AND WE CAN EXPECT TO CONTINUE TO
NOT MEET THE NEEDS IN THE WAY
OUR STUDENTS, REQUIRE AND
DESERVE. FOR THESE REASONS, WE
REQUEST THE ONGOING BUDGET
SUPPORT IN THE TO THE TUNE OF
$1.5 MILLION FOR THE HOMELESS
EDUCATION, TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
CENTERS. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. AND THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PATIENCE. LAST BUT NOT
LEAST, THANK YOU, CHAIR AND
MEMBERS, DEREK LENNOX, ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA COUNTY
SUPERINTENDENTS REPRESENTING THE
58 COUNTY SUPERINTENDENTS OF
SCHOOLS, I INTENTIONALLY STOOD
AT THE BACK OF THE LINE BECAUSE
THE MOST IMPORTANT MESSENGERS
ALREADY CAME BEFORE ME WHEN IT
CAME TO THE HOMELESS. EDUCATION,
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE CENTERS.
EVERY COUNTY OFFICE PLAYS A
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE ROLE IN
SUPPORTING THE DISTRICTS AND
STUDENTS IN THEIR COUNTY. SO THE
ONLY THING LEFT FOR ME TO SAY IS
THAT ON BEHALF OF THE 58 COUNTY
SUPERINTENDENTS, THEY'RE ALL
LENDING THEIR SUPPORT FOR THAT
PROPOSAL IN THE MESSAGES THAT
YOU HEARD EARLIER. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. WE
APPRECIATE YOUR COMMENTS, THAT
COMPLETES THE PUBLIC COMMENT.
AND COMPLETES, THE BUSINESS OF
THIS HEARING. I WANT TO
REITERATE THAT THAT, IF YOU
DIDN'T TESTIFY TODAY, AND YOU
WANT TO LET THE COMMITTEE KNOW
OF YOUR OPINIONS, MAKE SURE YOU
GO TO OUR WEB PAGE OR THAT WILL
ALSO GIVE THE ADDRESS TO WRITE.
AND IF ANY OF YOU FELT LIKE YOU
WERE TOO LIMITED IN YOUR
COMMENTS, FEEL FREE TO WRITE A
LETTER. EXPANDING ON WHAT, YOU
LET US KNOW SO THAT WE BENEFIT
FROM THEM, THAT CONCLUDES THE
BUSINESS FOR TODAY'S HEARING.
THE SENATE BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE,
ONE ON EDUCATION, STANDS
ADJOURNED